l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la première question va être posée par
laurence vichnievsky
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse au garde des
sceaux
monsieur le ministre l'accès et
l'exploitation des données de connexion
sont devenus depuis plusieurs années un
facteur majeur d'élucidation des
enquêtes pénales toutefois cette
technique denquête doit s'inscrire dans
le respect des libertés individuelles
hors la loi française parce qu'elle
permet au procureur de la république
d'accéder à ces données sans contrôle
préalable ou immédiatement ultérieure
d'une juridiction ou d'une entité
administrative indépendante est
contraire au droit de l'union cela
résulte des quatre arrêts de la cour de
cassation du 12 juillet dernier qui tire
les conséquences de décisions rendues
par la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
césar et énonce aussi que l'accès aux
données de connexion doit être justifiée
par l'objectif de prévention du
terrorisme ou de lutte contre la
criminalité grave mais qu'est ce que la
criminalité grave une loi devrait pour
le moins préciser cette notion afin de
sécuriser les procédures en cours et à
venir sur la question principale du
contrôle notre justice n'est pas en
mesure de faire face sans l'état aux
changements qu'induirait une mise en
conformité dans le seul département du
puy de dôme un tel contrôle
représenterait environ 5000 saisines
supplémentaires annuelles pour le
magistrat qui en seraient chargés la
conférence des procureurs de la
république s'en est inquiété auprès de
la représentation nationale
car cette situation risque d'entraver
sérieusement l'identification des
criminels et des délinquants
monsieur le ministre qu'envisagez-vous
face à cette situation la création d'une
entité administrative indépendante
dédiée au contrôle préalable ou bien
pensez vous confier ce contrôle au juge
des libertés et de la détention mais
dont il faudrait alors renforcer
fortement les effectifs je vous remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
eric dupond-moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
laurence vichnievsky je ne peux qu'aller
dans votre sens les arrêts de la cour de
cassation vous mentionnez sont des
arrêts qui sont extrêmement importants
ils ont d'ailleurs fait l'objet de
plusieurs dépêches de mes services au
parquet pour en expliquer la portée vous
l'avez rappelé la cour prend ici acte de
la jurisprudence de la cour de justice
de l'union européenne notamment dans
l'arrêt procurature mais la cour de
cassation indique que les données de
communication et de localisation ne
peuvent être obtenus que dans le cadre
d' enquêtes relatives à des infractions
d'une certaine gravité nous avions
d'ailleurs déjà défini ce critère par
référence au mandat d'arrêt européen qui
ne vise que les infractions punies d'au
moins 3 ans d'emprisonnement
il faudra poursuivre la réflexion
ensuite la cour exige pour censurer de
tels éléments de preuve obtenus que
l'irrégularité portent atteinte
concrètement aux droits de la personne
poursuivie je dois dire que la cour a
fait preuve ici d'un grand discernement
est beaucoup de pragmatisme
cette exigence permettra de sauvegarder
la plupart des procédures en cours comme
vous le soulignez madame la députée que
ce soit dans votre beau département du
puy de dôme ou à l'échelle de la france
entière l'impact serait absolument
significatif actuellement les services
d' enquête procède à près de deux
millions de réquisition par an il nous
faut trouver la solution juridiquement
robuste je pense par exemple aux
problèmes de constitutionnalité que
pourrait poser le fait de permettre à
une autorité administrative indépendante
d'intervenir dans une enquête judiciaire
mais également une solution qui prenne
en compte l'impact rh dans la
magistrature nous menons déjà cette
réflexion dans le cadre des états
généraux de la justice
nous travaillerons bien sûr en la
matière main dans la main avec le par le
monde merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre un
la parole est à monsieur grégoire de
furnaces
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur et des
outre mer
monsieur le ministre les incendies
historique en gironde- semble désormais
fixée après avoir brûlé plus de 20 mille
hectares et déplacé près de quarante
mille personnes malgré les efforts
surhumains déployés par les sapeurs
pompiers agents de la sécurité civile
gendarmes policiers élus et bénévoles je
veux les je veux saluer leur héroïsme
qui a permis de ne déplorer aucune
victime la réintégration des pompiers
nous vacciner serait d'ailleurs bien
utile au moment où chaque forces vives
compte des questions restent cependant
toujours sans réponse notamment sur le
nombre et la disponibilité des canadair
vous annonciez ici même le 19 juillet
dernier que la france disposer de la
plus grande flotte européenne en matière
de bombardier d'eau ce qui est un
mensonge car sans les avions
d'observation nous sommes derrière
l'italie et derrière l'espagne par
ailleurs le pré positionnement de cada
terre en gironde est réclamée par les
élus locaux depuis des années or
l'indisponibilité du tiers de la flotte
française à cause du manque d'entretien
a conduit à ce qu'aucun canadair ne soit
présent en gironde le 12 juillet quand
les incendies se sont déclarés vous nous
avez parlé d'une flotte européenne mais
elle serait constituée que de 12
canadair et deux seulement positionner
en france si cette force européenne
complémentaire est utile pour intervenir
sur les grands incendies de forêt il
nous faut préserver une force nationale
répartis sur le territoire en misant
tout sur ce programme européen vous
sacrifier la faute française et vous
mettez en péril notre capacité à agir
rapidement contre les incendies de forêt
les pilotes de canadair vous alertent
depuis des années sur le vieillissement
de leurs avions monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple quand comptez-vous
enfin agir pour que la france rattrape
son retard dans ce domaine afin d'éviter
que d'autres départements ne vivent le
même drame que celui de la gironde
je vous remercie la parole et à monsieur
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
et des outre-mer merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député je veux moi
aussi redire après treize jours de lutte
contre les flammes en gironde que les
pompiers les 2000 sapeurs pompiers qui
ont été mobilisés de gironde les
formations militaires comme les pompiers
de toute la france mérite notre respect
surtout que le bâti a été quasiment
intégralement conservée qu'il n'y a eu
aucune victime de ces méga feux je veux
aussi comme voulait les saluer
je veux me permettre monsieur le député
de si vous le souhaitez malheureusement
répondre à votre question n'étant pas
d'accord avec vous je redis ici que nous
avons la flotte la plus importante
d'europe y compris avec ou sans les
hélicoptères 35 hélicoptères qu'alors
que nous avons commandé puisque je
rappelle que le budget de la sécurité
civile augmenté de 44% sur le
quinquennat précédent il faut bien sûr
continuer cet effort je veux redire
qu'il ne s'agit pas de flotte européenne
mais que désormais c'est canadair sont
payés à 90 puis désormais à 100% par
l'union européenne donc on peut dire
aussi merci à l'europe je veux dire
que contrairement ce que vous avez
indiqué monsieur le député dès qu'on a
eu une alerte de gironde une heure après
les avions étaient en train de faire les
premiers largages au dessus de ces feux
ce qu'il ya derrière monsieur député
montrer qu'il n'y a pas eu deux shows
pétrolifère qui ont été attaqués et je
veux vous dire enfin monsieur députés
que s'agissant des pélicans c'est à dire
certains avions ils sont déjà
possiblement dans les landes ou dans la
nouvelle aquitaine de manière générale
et en gironde en particulier qu'il
faille réfléchir à la sécurité de six
villes de demain alors de réchauffement
climatique bien évidemment faisons le
ensemble trouvons pas de polémique là où
il y en a pas
souvent mais c'est ma seule ministre à
la parole est à monsieur charles rodwell
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à olivet du soft
ministre du travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur le ministre
depuis des décennies le sujet de
l'immigration s'inscrit au coeur de nos
débats c'est un enjeu majeur mais un
autre sujet pourtant fondamentale en est
absent c'est l'émigration les mairies si
l'émigration d'une part de notre
jeunesse qui quitte la france depuis des
années pour partir vivre étudier et
travailler à l'étranger cette émigration
notre majorité ne sied jamais résigné
beaucoup de ces jeunes qui t'a france
parce qu'il n'y trouvent pas de travail
nous nous avons fait du travail le socle
de notre politique et les résultats sont
là 1,3 million d'emplois créés en cinq
ans
sept cent mille contrats d'apprentissage
signés chaque année
autant de jeunes qui restent en france
pour y travailler et qui font la
richesse de notre pays grâce à notre
action menée depuis cinq ans nous avons
parcouru la moitié du chemin il nous
reste la seconde moitié trop de jeunes
pourtant bien formés continue de ne pas
trouver de travail en france ceci alors
que de nombreux secteurs sont en pénurie
chronique de main d'oeuvre ce paradoxe à
une cause principale nous orientons trop
de jeunes vers des métiers qui
n'embauchent pas et nous n'aurions pas
assez de jeunes vers des métiers qui
embauchent
ma question est donc la suivante quelle
est votre stratégie pour mieux former et
orienter nos jeunes vers les filières
qui leur donneront du travail merci je
vous remercie la parole est à monsieur
olivier dussopt ministre du travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
rodwell votre constat est juste et
d'abord il faut le rappeler en cinq ans
ce sont un million trois cent mille
emplois qui ont été créés en france dont
750 milles au cours des deux dernières
années malgré la pandémie et malgré les
difficultés économiques aujourd'hui il
ya deux points qui doivent tous que
mobiliser de points que vous avez
rappelé d'abord détention de recrutement
nous avons des jeunes formés mais nous
avons aussi beaucoup de professionnels
qui ont des difficultés à recruter nous
avons 7 3% de chômage et malgré tout
tous les jours des chefs d'entreprise
nous disent ne pas avoir de possibilité
de recrutement ne pas trouver personnel
face à cela nous mettons tout en oeuvre
pour inciter à la reprise du travail
cela passe par des réformes qui ont été
mises en oeuvre au cours des dernières
années je pense à celles de l'assurance
chômage que nous allons vous proposer de
prendre roger cela passe aussi par la
mise en oeuvre d'un plan de réduction
des tensions de recrutement avec la
monuc la mobilisation du service public
de l'emploi avec la volonté aussi
d'accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée en les formant pour qu'ils
puissent avoir les compétences répondant
aux besoins des entreprises depuis
octobre 2021 ce sont un million quatre
cent mille off qui ont été pourvus et
surtout ce sont 240 mille demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée qui ont pu
retrouver un emploi et donc retrouver
l'autonomie et l'émancipation et puis il
ya une piste plus structurelle qui
touche à la formation nous avons des
priorités des priorités de fond la
formation par apprentissage
730 milles apprentis cette année un
objectif à un million d'apprentis nous
avons un autre objectif structurelles
revaloriser les filières
professionnelles la voie professionnelle
pour faire en sorte que la voie
professionnelle soit qualifiante et
permettent un débouché dans l'emploi
avec des perspectives de carrière ces
deux chantiers l'apprentissage et la
réforme de la voie professionnelle
je n'aimerais pas seul j'aimerais
évidemment pour la voie professionnelle
avec mon collègue me de l'éducation je
les mènerai bien sûr avec carole
grandjean nice délégué en charge de
l'enseignement et des formations
professionnelles c'est elle qui pilotera
ce chantier pour faire en sorte que la
voie professionnelle et l'apprentissage
soit encore plus des filières
d'excellence et encore plus des réponses
aux besoins de l'économie d'aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur andy kerbrat
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres collègue
monsieur le ministre de la santé de la
prévention
depuis le mois de juin on ne cesse de
vous interpeller sur la nécessité d'une
action rapide pour stopper la
circulation de la variole du singe il y
a aujourd'hui 1700 car en france et l'
oms a décrété l'état d'urgence mondial
face à l'épidémie l'inquiétude grandit
il aura fallu que les médias à l'ère
pour que vous sortiez enfin de votre
mutisme en un an sans un grand centre de
vaccination à paris c'est un premier pas
mais rien pour le reste du pays qui
représentent 54 % des cas de
contamination
puisque la prévention est désormais dans
l'intitulé de votre portefeuille nous
attendions au moins une campagne de
prévention et d'information hélas
toujours rien
votre silence fait des victimes combien
contamination peut être évité grâce et
des diagnostics plus rapide
comme pour la crise qu vide on croit
revivre le même film des départements
sont privés de vaccins on bataille pour
obtenir un rendez-vous de vaccination de
dépistage les publics les plus éloignés
et les plus précaires sont une nouvelle
fois les premières victimes comme les
travailleurs du sexe
vous devez tirer les leçons du passé il
faut agir vite il faut agir dans la
transparence
il faut le faire avec les associations
et les professionnels pour faciliter le
filippi des milk la haute autorité de
santé vous demande de généraliser et de
rembourser les tests en laboratoire de
ville vous devez le faire
les associations vous recommande de
distribuer les doses aux généralistes et
aux pharmaciens vous devez le faire
qu'attendez vous monsieur le ministre
c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir
comme pour le vih l'invisibilisation est
une discrimination
c'est de plus en plus ressentie comme
une nouvelle marque de mépris par les
personnes exposées ces gens là comme le
dit votre collègue vous devez garantir
l'accès au vaccin qui existe pourtant
depuis 2011 seuls 3 trente mille doses
ont été déstocker pour au moins 250
personnes exposées doit-on en déduire
que la france manque encore de vaccin
nos concitoyens sont en droit de savoir
le niveau de compétence de leur mise et
la santé il sert à rien vous drapez dans
le secret défense pour cacher votre
incompétence
merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame agnès firmin le
bodo ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député on dit
kerbart à une question calme je vais
essayer d'apporter une réponse calme en
effet depuis le début mai 2000 22 mai
2000 22 des cas d'infection à la variole
du singe sont observés dans plusieurs
pays dont la france et bien sûr et
l'europe est une région endémiques comme
vous l'avez justement dit en france au
25 juillet 2022 il y avait mille sept
cent quarante neuf cas confirmés dont
près de la moitié en ile de france si la
rémission de l'infection se fait
effectivement deux à trois semaines sans
séquelles durables la maladie peut être
douloureuse ayant ici une pensée pour
toutes ce tout tous ceux qui en
souffrent et qui en ont souffert je veux
être très clair monsieur le député je
lutterai avec l'ensemble de mes
collègues avec force contre les discours
de haine et de stigmatisation en lien
avec ma collègue elisabeth rome si la
majorité des personnes touchées sont des
hommes qui ont des relations sexuelles
avec des partenaires multiples cela ne
signifie en rien en rien que le virus ne
touche que les hommes homosexuels
face à cela nous avons agi et ce très
tôt les premières personnes contacts à
risque ont été vaccinées dès le premier
avis de la has le 24 mai par ailleurs je
voudrais insister sur le fait que nous
sommes l'un des tout premiers pays et
vous auriez pu le dire au monde à avoir
proposé une vaccination préventive est
prise en charge totalement en effet en
effet en effet saisi dès notre arrivée
au ministère le 4 juillet dernier la has
a rendu dès le 8 juillet un avis
proposant d'élargir le public éligibles
à la vaccination
il s'agit des hommes ayant des relations
sexuelles avec des hommes
multipartenaires des personnes trans
multipartenaires des personnes en
situation de prostitution ou des
professionnels exerçant dans les lieux
de consommation sexuelle nous avons
immédiatement suivi cet avis puisque les
premières vaccinations ont pu avoir lieu
dès le 11 juillet l'alertent de ems date
du 23 juillet monsieur le député à ceux
d'at c'est bien 114 centres de
vaccination qui sont tous ouverts et
plus de 6100 personnes vaccinées merci
beaucoup madame la ministre à
la parole est à monsieur benjamin lucas
merci même la présidente
homme libre toujours tu chériras la mer
par ce ver baudelaire décrit
l'irrépressible besoin humain de
l'évasion de la contemplation du voyage
ce droit au bonheur et même gravé dans
le marbre de notre histoire républicaine
depuis les congés payés le front
populaire de 1936 et il l'est dans le
marbre du droit à l'article 142 la loi
du 29 juillet 1998 qui dispose que
l'égal accès de tous tout au long de la
vie aux vacances et aux loisirs
constituent un objectif national ce
droit aux vacances et pourtant refusé à
des millions de familles cette année
encore et encore plus du fait de la vie
chère du prix des carburants des bas
salaires que vous avez refusé
d'augmenter de votre maltraitance des
services publics du monde associatif et
les collectivités locales des millions
d'enfants de précaires de salariés de
retraités ne verront ni la mère ni la
montagne ni notre exceptionnel
patrimoine
le jour de la rentrée plus de 3 millions
d'élèves se sentiront exclus de ce
moment merveilleux où l'on raconte son
et et ses découvertes source de la
construction des imaginaires des rêves
donc de la liberté de l'esprit cette
injustice accentue les phénomènes de
sédentarité le mal être psychologique
les inégalités sociales culturelles et
éducatives il est possible d'agir sur
les moyens pour assurer l'égalité de
tous dans l'accès aux vacances sur
l'accompagnement culturel et pédagogique
sur le renforcement d'une offre de
tourisme social et écologique alors ma
question est simple
le gouvernement est il prêt à et il
prépare donc à appliquer enfin la loi et
à faire de ce droit aux vacances une
réalité pour toutes les familles dans
notre pays je vous remercie
la parole
est à sa raillerie secrétaire d'état
chargée de la jeunesse et du service
national universel
merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député luca les vacances évidemment
émancipe les vacances évidemment donne
les moyens à notre jeunesse de respirer
et de s'oxygéner mais monsieur le député
depuis 2010 est notre obsession lab
session de cette majorité de ce
gouvernement c'est de permettre aux
jeunes de partir et de partir en
vacances de manière très immédiate grâce
aux plans vacances apprenantes grâce au
plan tourisme social c'est presque un
million d'enfants un million de jeunes
qui sont partis 250000 monsieur le
député grâce aux colo apprenantes plus
de 400 mille familles accompagnées grâce
à l'investissement des enseignants plus
de 2000 établissements qui sont ouverts
pour leur permettre d'apprendre de
respirer de rigoler de se faire de
nouveaux copains mais au-delà de cette
question plus urgente
et bien nous allons en profondeur
redynamiser un secteur celui de
l'économie de l'animation de l'économie
sociale et solidaire celui du tourisme
social avec l'éducation populaire avec
ses acteurs avec qui on permet grâce à
la mobilisation de tout le gouvernement
est bien de mettre des moyens dans le
bâti de le rénover de permettre avec les
enseignants de permettre à des familles
plus éloignés de pouvoir permettre à
leurs enfants de bénéficier d'une prise
en charge jusqu'à 80% du départ 400
euros par semaine par chacune de ses
familles et avec la première ministre à
l'époque ministre du travail nous avons
déployé un jeune une solution qui permet
aux jeunes de découvrir leurs droits
encore plus loin parce qu'avec l' agence
nationale des chèques vacances nous
permettons aux 18 25 ans de bénéficier
de 200 à 250 euros par semaine
permettant à ces jeunes et bien de
partir avec leurs copains de découvrir
leurs droits monsieur le député plus que
jamais notre combat c'est d'accompagner
les acteurs de l'éducation populaire nos
enseignants les familles les plus
modestes en faisant attention aux plus
jeunes les plus en difficultés les plus
fragiles les jeunes ruraux mais
également les jeunes en situation de
handicap
je vous remercie
et c'est le cas
merci madame la présidente je suis
surpris que pour répondre à une question
qui concerne l'émancipation l'avenir le
droit au bonheur le gouvernement
choisisse de faire répondre une ministre
placée sous l'autorité du ministère des
armées je crois qu'il ya là une forme de
provocation à la haine toutes les
associations que nous rencontrons toutes
les collectivités j'étais à poitiers
encore hier disent que vous n'aurez pas
la parole est un lycée jean pierre
vigier
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente madame la
première ministre notre groupe politique
a fait de la baisse des prix à la pompe
une priorité absolue face à la formule
des prix des carburants grâce à notre
mobilisation sans faille nous et oui
c'est bien nous les républicains qui
avons obtenu de réelles avancées pour
les français en obtenant une ristourne
de l'état de 30 centimes par litre
contre 10,8 au début et une remise de 20
centimes de total soit une baisse de 50
centimes par litre de carburant à la
pompe qui sera effective dès septembre
j'ajoute également les 230 millions
d'euros d' aide pour les ménages qui se
chauffent au fioul et les 15 millions
d'euros de soutien aux stations service
en milieu rural je le dis haut et fort
il est vital de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat à tous les français je pense en
particulier aux habitants dans nos
territoires ruraux asphyxié par
l'inflation et des taxes record ils
souffrent plus spécifiquement cependant
ces mesures vont dans le bon sens ne
sont qu'un début elle ne serait être
suffisante sur le long terme seriez vous
donc prête madame la première ministre a
baissé de manière pérenne les taxes sur
les carburants comme nous vous le
demandons depuis plusieurs semaines déjà
enfin alors que la ristourne à la pompe
doit s'arrêter en fin d'année
pouvez-vous clairement nous garantir
qu'elle sera prolongée si les prix du
pétrole ne baisse toujours pas d'ici là
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur gabriel attal ministre chargé
des comptes publics
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean pierre vigier nous sommes réunis
depuis plusieurs jours et plusieurs
nuits pour travailler ensemble à des
mesures pour lutter contre l'inflation
phénomène mondial qui touche également
nos compatriotes qui a été accentuée par
la guerre en ukraine mais qui avait
démarré avant il y a un an nous avons
fait un choix nous avons fait un choix
d'agir résolument face à l'inflation
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français
depuis nous sommes le pays dans les pays
comparables qui a adopté le plus large
paquet pour le pouvoir d'achat est celui
de la zone euro où l'inflation est la
plus faible c'est parce que nous avons
agi depuis un an avec des mesures
particulièrement forte
évidemment nous continuons à agir et à
prendre des mesures adaptées c'est tout
le sens des travaux qui nous ont réunis
vous l'avez dit c'est derniers jours
nous avions une proposition qui était
d'éteindre progressivement la ristourne
de carburant et de lui substituer un
nouveau dispositif il y a eu des
échanges est effectivement notamment
avec votre groupe nous avons adopté un
autre dispositif qui est la prolongation
de la ristourne carburant son
renforcement total est venu aussi
apporté une ristourne supplémentaire ce
qui fait comme vous l'avez dit au mois
de septembre c'est 50 centimes de baisse
au litre ces massifs et là il ya aussi
peu de comparable au niveau européen je
veux le souligner je veux souligner les
autres amendements sont venus enrichir
vous avez cités celui de monsieur des
coeurs donc nous avons toujours montré
que nous répondions présents mais nous
avons aussi toujours dit la vérité aux
français ça n'est pas vrai de dire que
l'état peut seul prendre à sa charge les
effets de l'inflation nous ne pouvons
pas faire croire cela aux français parce
que la réalité c'est que nous devons
aussi tenir nos finances publiques pour
ne pas reporter des impôts sur les
années et les générations suivantes il
faut assumer nos responsabilités et donc
la ligne qui est la nôtre c'est aussi de
faire participer les entreprises nous
avons adopté c'est à l'initiative de
plusieurs groupes de cet hémicycle dont
le vôtre un abonnement qui permet de
doubler la prime défiscalisées pour les
entreprises et leurs salariés en matière
de cartes enfin vous voyez nous
continuons à agir tous ensemble
la parole est à monsieur vigier monsieur
le ministre il y a des priorités aider
les français sur ce thème est je le
rappelle c'est la mobilisation des
républicains qui a permis d'arriver à
cbs il faut simplement pérenniser ces
baisses c'est important pour les
français merci
javaux metz
m
s'il vous plaît la parole est à madame
stella dupont
merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture chers
collègues la france est fortement
impacté par l'épidémie d'influenza
aviaire la découverte de foyers
hautement pathogène a forcé l'abattage
de plus de 16 millions de volailles dans
le pays le maine-et-loire la vendée et
la région des pays de la loire sont
particulièrement impactés et j'associe
mes collègues députés présents autour de
moi sur ce sujet je salue le travail des
services des directions départementales
de la protection des populations qui
sont en première ligne ainsi que celui
des chambres d'agriculture et des
messins qui s'attache à accompagner les
exploitants concernés je salue aussi
tous les acteurs de la filière et
particulièrement les éleveurs impacter
directement ou indirectement et qu'ils
ont subis et qui subissent encore cette
épidémie virulente et violente mais qui
sont aussi acteurs pour maîtriser cette
épidémie et je pense notamment aux
actions de dépeuplement que je salue et
je les en remercie les préjudices liés à
cette crise sont estimés à plus d'un
milliard d'euros car c'est toute la
filière qui a été touché l'élevage mais
aussi l'amont avec les accouveurs et
toute la génétique laval avec l'abattage
et l'agro alimentaire ce sont des
milliers d'emplois chers collègues qui
ont été affectés avec une activité
partielle forte avec un reste à charge
de ce chômage partiel qui pèsent sur les
trésoreries des entreprises et des
exploitations on a donc du chômage des
frais d'abattage et des pertes
d'exploitation massive depuis le mois de
mars date de l'arrêt de la production
dans mon secteur
la reprise des productions est en cours
mais tel est lente et fragile les
filières et les éleveurs en particulier
sont en train de recevoir les as contre
concernant les frais d'abattage mais ils
sont dans la tente du niveau des aides
économiques auxquels ils pourront
prétendre et ils rencontrent des
problèmes de trésorerie l'interruption
de leur activité étant perçue comme
interminable la détresse est forte car
l'incertitude est forte ainsi monsieur
le ministre pouvez vous nous préciser
les dispositifs et le calendrier précis
des aides des versements à venir pour
répondre efficacement aux conséquences
de la crise ya la grippe aviaire en
tenant compte de la diversité des types
des modalités de production et d homère
c'est la parole est un monsieur marc
raynaud ministre de l'agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire merci
beaucoup madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée stella dupont je vois d'abord
vous remercier de cette question qui me
permet de faire un point d'étape sur
cette grippe aviaire c'est influenza
aviaire depuis 2015 quatre épisodes de
successifs et le plus virulent c'est
celui que nous connaissons puisque trois
fois plus de départements touchés
surtout c'est bon il ya des départements
des parlementaires qui savent que les
départements sont touchés 18 18 fois
plus de foyers c'est autant de détresse
et de sujets humains qui sont devant
nous je signale en outre que l'influenza
continue à circuler plus tôt en faune
sauvage et ça ne manque pas de nous
inquiéter ce qui nécessite d'ailleurs
que nous continuons à déployer les
outils de prévention et de détection
précoce du virus
l'amélioration encore des pratiques en
termes de biosécurité évidemment une
meilleure gestion de crise c'est tout
l'objet du plan d'action que je
présenterai vendredi avec les acteurs de
la filière et qui a été travaillé avec
eux ils prendre en compte en outre le
fait que dans le secteur en particulier
de la courage qui a été très touché
c'est une particularité de cette crise
on a besoin de mieux répartir et de
mieux gérer le me lamenter en charge
dans un certain nombre d'élevages
simplement l'état et est continûment
rendez vous depuis cette crise et et les
éleveurs le savent et le disent
d'ailleurs pour donner des éléments
concrets sur le volet sanitaire 200
millions de sont prévus dans le plfr
actuellement un examen et sera le besoin
sera affinée en cours de route d'ici la
fin de l'année une fois tous les
dossiers déposés sur le volet économique
26 millions pour 1800 dossier pour le
sud ouest et le nord 2 millions pour le
dispositif 9,1 en cours de déploiement
86 millions pour le disque dispositif d'
avance des éleveurs du grand ouest ça
vous concerne plus particulièrement 25
millions pour le dispositif d'avancés
remboursables à destination de l'aval
des entreprises agroalimentaires enfin
un dispositif spécial sur la couvert la
couv h sera ouvert d'ici la fin de l'été
les paiements des bureaux seront au fin
d'automne l' enveloppe totale allouée
est de plus de 120 millions d'euros vous
l'avez souligné madame la députée
l'ensemble des services de l'état ont
été mobilisés jours fériés compris
depuis le début de l'année pour
accompagner les éleveurs y compris la
compagnie dans les situations de
détresse dans lesquelles ils sont on
continuera de travailler avec eux y
compris pour avoir un plan de résilience
pour effet essayer de mieux lutter
contre ces influences à qui revient
malheureusement beaucoup plus
régulièrement dans notre territoire
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur marcellin nadeau
merci merci madame la présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et a
trait à la situation des enseignants néo
titulaires dans l'es10 outre-mer j'y
associe d'ailleurs l'ensemble des élus
de cette région et territoires qui sont
comme moi légitimement préoccupés par
cette situation
quand vous le savez ces néo titulaires
sont des enseignants qui en tant que
contractuels ont rendu quelques fois
pendant de longues années de bons et
loyaux services au système éducatif dans
nos pays et qui passant les concours
nationaux de l'éducation nationale se
voient systématiquement affectés hors de
nos régions respectives
et s'agissant de la martinique or de
martinique alors que dans le même temps
existe dans les académies concernées des
postes vacants souvent pourvus par des
enseignants notamment contractuels
venant de l'hexagone nous demandons
monsieur le ministre que cette question
soit urgemment réglé dans un esprit
d'équité et de transparence
c'est une situation incompréhensible
quand on sait que l'on donne aux pays
déjà confrontés à de graves problèmes de
dépeuplement c'est par exemple 4600
jeune martiniquaise et martiniquais qui
partent chaque année afin de trouver
dans l'hexagone des perspectives
d'emploi avec très peu de garanties de
pouvoir rentrer pour travailler et vivre
dans leur pays et pourtant ce sont des
forces vives de notre jeunesse en mesure
de porter le projet de développement
durable de nature à régler durablement
les grappes problématique que
connaissent nos pays c'est pourquoi nous
demandons au delà des cas individuels de
cette année particulièrement préoccupant
et en attendant un plan d'urgence de
l'éducation nécessaire pour nos pays que
des solutions soient rapidement mises en
oeuvre pour régler ce problème des néo
titulaires
oui monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire donc pour régler
définitivement cette situation qui prend
des tour dramatique ce sont des femmes
et des hommes que l'on arrache à leur
territoire a le vie familiale mejia leur
vie affective
la parole est un monsieur pape ndiaye et
du ministre de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
nadeau l'affectation des enseignants
dans les différentes académies est en
effet une tâche prioritaire pour mon
ministère c'est vrai dans toutes les
académies de métropole c'est vrai aussi
dans les cinq académies d'outre-mer plus
encore du fait de l'éloignement cela
concerne à la fois les enseignants qui
viennent de réussir un concours les
stagiaires et les néo titulaires et ceux
qui aspirent à une mobilité géographique
pour convenances personnelles ou pour
des raisons familiales
concernant ces enseignants originaires
des territoires ultramarins
il bénéficie désormais d'une priorité
légal d'affectation et de mutations
fondé sur la reconnaissance de leur
centre des intérêts matériels et moraux
le sim cette priorité doit cependant
s'accorder avec d'autres priorités le
rapprochement de conjoint et la
situation éventuelle de handicap
l'ensemble de ces situations peuvent
avoir pour conséquence que des
enseignants n'obtiennent pas c'est vrai
toujours l'académie correspondant à leur
premier choix toutes les situations
individuelles liées à des situations de
famille ou à lille l'éloignement sont
étudiées avec soin par le ministère afin
de trouver la solution la plus adaptée
avec mon collègue ministre d outre mer
nous sommes très attentifs à la
situation des enseignants
ultramarins est tout disposé à échanger
avec vous sur ce sujet j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'entretenir récemment
également avec les présidents de région
de martinique et de guadeloupe
c'est un dossier important sur lequel
nous nous penchons avec grande attention
et je suis comme je vous le disais à
votre disposition ainsi qu'à celle des
députés ultramarins pour avancer sur la
question
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur laurent jacobellis
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères le 19 juillet dernier les 27
membres de l'union européenne ont
annoncé l'ouverture des négociations
d'adhésion de l'albanie et de la
macédoine du nord quelle drôle d'idée le
monstre technocratique européen ne
fonctionne déjà pas à 27 comment
pourrait-il fonctionner à 29 les peuples
européens al'inverse de leurs dirigeants
ont bien compris que chaque
élargissement était un affaiblissement
qui condamnent l'union européenne à
l'impuissance et la france au déclin oui
les français savent que l'union
européenne et la france ont tout à
perdre en acceptant leur mise en
concurrence avec des pays dans lesquels
le salaire minimum ne dépasse pas 300
euros mensuels c'est le nivellement
salariale par le bas qui s'annonce la
concurrence déloyale entre salariés qui
se profile les français savent aussi que
dans notre pays déjà incapable de
contrôler les flux migratoires qui
entraîne une perte d'identité et de
sécurité et creusot caisses sociales que
notre pays ne doit surtout pas accepter
l'intégration de pays devenu porte
d'entrée d'une émigration clandestine
massive en europe la france confronté à
l'explosion de la criminalité des
trafics en tous genres se doit de
refuser l'intégration de l'albanie
véritable narco état grand green et par
la corruption et le règle de mafia qui l
ont bien compris que l'adhésion à
l'union européenne représenterait une
aubaine pour le développement du crime
organisé en europe de l'ouest cette
course irraisonnée à l'élargissement
doit cesser la france déjà contributeurs
nets au budget européen devra mettre
encore plus au pot pour l'adhésion de
ces nouveaux pays les contribuables
français déjà exemple vont donc devoir
payer pour la baisse de leurs salaires
la délocalisation de leurs emplois
une immigration massive et une
criminalité incontrôlée cet
irresponsable
ma question madame la ministre est
simple comment pouvez-vous justifier
devant les français ces adhésions futur
mais affaibliront la france tous merci
beaucoup
la parole est à madame laurence boone
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'europe
merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs et député monsieur
le député jacques aubé lee
tout d'abord je crois que nous le savons
tous l'europe n'est plus la même depuis
le 24 février 2022 la guerre en ukraine
a tout bouleversé
et nous avons su en prendre acte en
accordant effectivement le statut de
candidat à l'ukraine et la moldavie et
avec le processus d'adhésion de la
macédoine du nord à union européenne
ainsi que pour l'allemagne
ces décisions sont historiques et elle
nous renforce tous et ce ne sont pas de
vaines promesses
car ces pays rentreront effectivement un
jour dans l'union européenne et il était
évidemment capital de leur envoyer un
signal très clair sur cette perspective
nous
mais entendons-nous bien
1 le processus d'adhésion prendra du
temps de nous n'avait seront pas les
standards européens et 3 la
réversibilité peut s'appliquer si nous
observons hercules et nous serons très
vigilants pour que ce processus se
déroule dans les meilleures consid
conditions et le respect de nos intérêts
deux autres points sur le salaire
minimum
c'est une des avancées majeures de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne que tous les pays de l'union
européenne se soit engagé sur le sujet
sur le code schengen la france dans sa
présidence de l'union européenne a
réussi à débloquer
ce code qui était depuis longtemps à
l'état où il devait être réformée avec
plus de responsabilité et une meilleure
procédure de filtrage
laissez moi vous dire une chose
soit nous arrivons ces pays à l'union
européenne
soit nous les laissons s'arrimer à des
puissances qui ne nous veulent pas du
bien je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame pascale martin
madame madame la présidente ce monsieur
le ministre après avoir été conseiller
spécial du candidat emmanuel macron sur
les questions de santé vous voilà donc
ministre de la santé en charge de mettre
en oeuvre les préconisations du rapport
tiré de la mission flash que vous avez
vous même mené en refusant de vous
attaquer aux racines de cette crise
profonde attractivité des métiers
rémunération et pénurie de
professionnels vous poursuivez la
politique de casse du service des
urgences
initié par madame busin que vous
critiquer sévèrement par ailleurs pire
vous l'accentuer les principales
propositions tirées par la mission flash
sont centrés sur un seul objectif
dissuader la population de se présenter
aux urgences vous vous proposez donc de
fonctionner en mode dégradé en triant
les patients
la fermeture de services est présenté
comme un nouveau mode de fonctionnement
dans mon département de la dordogne
confrontés aux déserts médicaux et
aujourd'hui à l'afflux de touristes la
situation d urgence sur le territoire
arrive à un niveau critique avec des
fermetures inopinées l'hôpital de sarlat
déjà fermé ses urgences pendant une
journée et celui de bergerac qui
fonctionne avec six praticiens
hospitaliers sur quinze postes temps
plein vient de le faire une suractivité
du 15 à l'hôpital de périgueux ne
pouvant être absorbé par l'effectif
actuel sans forcément de celui ci met en
danger la population avec des durées
d'attenté au téléphone de plus de six
minutes elle engendre de fait une perte
de chance considérable voire
inacceptable pour les patients et
patientes qui connaîtront
inéluctablement des drames la fermeture
annoncée de 72 lits pour cette période
de deux mois participera activement à
cette catastrophe sanitaire
monsieur le ministre quand allez vous
donner les moyens humains et financiers
au service d urgence pour fonctionner
quand allez vous vous décidez à
réintégrer le personnel soignant non
vaccinés merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame agnès firmin le
bodo au ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés et madame la députée pascale
martin en effet notre système de santé
connaît actuellement des problèmes
structurels qui ne sont pas nouveaux
importants que depuis deux années et
demie la crise sanitaire a
particulièrement mise en exergue
l'application de nos personnels
soignants est totale et ici nous le
savons tous et ce sont eux qui tiennent
notre système de santé nous comptons pas
leurs heures et je veux ici le rendre
hommage comme ça a déjà été fait à de
nombreuses reprises les constats sont
connus et vous les avez énuméré
démographie médicale inadapté aux
besoins déserts médicaux mauvaise
articulation entre la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital personnel soignant en quête
de sens métier en perte d'attractivité
politique de prévention insuffisamment
développée face à cela des choses ont
déjà été faites très clairement ces
dernières années l'exemple du ségur de
la santé et des moyens jamais alloué à
l'hôpital en sont une preuve tangible
mais nous devons aller plus loin pour
régler ses problèmes structurels
accumulées depuis des décennies c'est
tout le sens que pondre à la conférence
des parties prenantes qui permettra dans
la concertation en écoutant d'abord ce
que nous disent les français et quels
sont leurs besoins de bâtir des
solutions pour mieux articuler le
système entre médecine de ville et puis
et hôpital pour que chaque français
puisse être prise en charge de manière
adéquate lorsqu'il en a besoin
les parlementaires devront y être
associés et département vous pouvez
compter sur mon engagement et je
m'inscris en faux sur le fait de dire
que le fait d'appeler le 15 diminue une
chance pour nos concitoyens le 15 permet
de réguler et de permettre à tous nos
concitoyens d'avoir accès aux soins
soient aux urgences soins médecine de
ville
madame lavigne ce train la parole est à
monsieur david valence
madame la présidente
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé de la prévention
j'y associe mes collègues députés de
paris clara chassagnol et de
charente-maritime raphaël gérard
monsieur le ministre samedi dernier le
directeur général de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a déclaré une
urgence sanitaire de portée
internationale à propos de l'orthodoxie
virose simienne dit variole du singe si
le risque reste modérée à l'échelle
internationale il est d'ores et déjà
élevé en europe selon les experts c'est
depuis mai 2000 22 que des cas de
variole du singe sont rapportés hors du
continent africain depuis lors le virus
aurait déjà affecté au moins dix sept
mille personnes dans plus de 70 mille
pays de 70 pays en france
1567 cas étaient recensés pour cette
maladie à déclaration obligatoire la
semaine dernière pour 1749 hier lundi la
maladie demeure bénigne dans la grande
majorité des cas mais elle peut se
révéler très douloureuse par les lésions
cutanées qu'elle entraîne à ce jour près
de 95% des personnes touchées par le
virus en france sont des hommes jeunes
ayant eu des partenaires sexuels
masculins dans les jours précédant
l'apparition des symptômes
le gouvernement et notre organisation
sanitaire ont réagi rapidement ces
dernières semaines pour faire face à
cette pandémie naissante un numéro vert
a été mis en place pour informer pour
conseiller pour orienter une vaccination
sur base antivariolique s'est mise en
place en région grand est des centres de
vaccination fonctionne déjà dans quatre
départements par exemple ils ont d'abord
accueilli les seuls cas contacts mais
toutes les personnes considérées comme à
risque ils y ont désormais accès
monsieur le ministre malgré ces mesures
précoces l'inquiétude est très vive chez
beaucoup de me sexuelle hommes de notre
pays dans leur famille face à ce virus
encore mal connue
je sais que vous en êtes conscient
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous par
conséquent nous présenter la manière
dont vous appréhender le risque de
pandémie
ainsi que nous exposer la stratégie
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame
agnès firmin le bodo même si leurs
collègues de veiller au respect du temps
pour moi madame ministre chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
provisions de santé vous avez la pole
merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
monsieur le député david valence merci
de poser cette question qui va me
permettre de pouvoir compléter la
réponse à la question faites
précédemment comme vous l'avez souligné
la diffusion de cette maladie humaine
mondiale inédite la variole du singe est
observée depuis plusieurs semaines avec
près de 16000 car dans le monde et 8000
qu'un en europe merci d'avoir rappelé
est de tordre le cou à l'idée que les
autorités soient ni sanitaires
françaises n'ont pas réagit vite l on a
réagi très vite elles sont pleinement
mobilisés depuis le mois de mai en ayant
classé la variole du singe dans les
maladies à déclaration obligatoire et en
assurant l'entière mobilisation des
laboratoires professionnels
établissements de santé la france est le
premier pays en europe et oui à cette
inscrire dans cette dynamique
d'anticipation
le chiffre des injections quotidiennes
est en constante augmentation avec près
de 1200 injections réalisées le 21
juillet et plus de 114 centres de
vaccination aujourd'hui ouverts ce
mouvement est appelé à se poursuivre et
a continué à accélérer cela nous place
parmi les pays les plus volontariste en
la matière le déclenchement du seuil d
alerte par l' oms vient confirmer que
cette mobilisation est nécessaire et
doit s'inscrire dans la durée ainsi nous
poursuivrons la sensibilisation des
professionnels pour qu'il soit
pleinement mobilisés et nous
renforcerons les messages de prévention
en lien avec les associations pour
limiter la diffusion de l'épidémie nous
travaillerons également avec nos
homologues européens cette semaine pour
une stratégie coordonnée je souhaite par
ailleurs le dire et le redire nous
n'avons pas de problème lié au nombre de
doses disponibles
42 me ont déjà été déstocker le
déstockage des dos va se poursuivre dans
les prochaines semaines autant que
nécessaire en fonction des demandes
remontées du terrain par les ars et des
commandes complémentaires ont été
passées pour répondre à l'ensemble de la
demande de vaccination dans les
prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à monsieur guillaume garot
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre de la santé je veux
aujourd'hui vous interroger sur la
désertification médicale
ce sont 8 millions de français qui sont
concernés et c'est une très grande
inquiétude quand votre médecin part à la
retraite et qu'il n'est pas remplacé et
quand le gouvernement nous dit en plus
qu'il ne faut pas aller engorger les
urgences alors moi je ne sais pas
comment on fait parce que précisément on
se tourne vers les urgences quand on n'a
plus de médecin c'est une grande
inquiétude mais c'est aussi une grande
injustice parce que selon le territoire
où on habite on n'a pas le même accès
aux soins est pas le même accès
évidemment à la santé alors l'enjeu
c'est de trouver des solutions
rapidement très rapidement et pas
échéance de 10 ans le temps de former
une nouvelle génération de médecins
parce que jusqu'à présent ce qui a été
mis en oeuvre par les gouvernements
précédents n'a pas produit les résultats
attendus et pire nous le voyons bien
dans nos territoires la situation
s'aggrave alors nous sommes ici nombreux
sur tous les bancs à penser que les
réponses d'hier ne valent plus
aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas de solution
sans régulation de l'installation des
médecins généralistes et spécialistes
comme cela existe pour d'autres
professions santé je pense aux
pharmaciens en particulier pour assurer
la meilleure répartition possible sur
l'ensemble du territoire
j'ai pris l'initiative avec les députés
socialistes ici à l'assemblée de créer
un travail un groupe de travail trans
partisan pour proposer d'ici l'automne
des solutions enfin efficace alors nous
avons pu vérifier nos convergences et
nous travaillerons avec tous ceux qui
veulent avancer sur le sujet monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement se dit prêt au
compromis alors passons aux actes êtes
vous prêts à agir sur la base des
propositions que nous vous ferons nous
élus ferrain pour résorber au legs la
parole est à madame agnès firmin le bodo
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
garot tout d'abord je tiens à excuser
l'absence de monsieur brawn retenu au
sénat si fait que c'est madame la
ministre qui est présente
merci monsieur garot tout le monde
connaît votre engagement depuis des
années sur ce sujet de la
désertification médicale tout le monde
sait ici aussi après avoir fait deux
campagnes une campagne présidentielle
une campagne législative que ce sujet
nous concerne tous tous ici présents
monsieur le député d'or de la dernière
législature précédente dans le déni
quatre canards des mesures ont été
prises et vous l'avez dit vous-même la
suppression du numerus clausus on sait
très bien qu'elles produiront des
résultats dans le temps long les
infirmières de pratiques avancées elles
sont en cours de formation elles vont
finir par s'installer les auxiliaires
médicaux qui se déploie puisque 2500
sont déployés et vont permettre de
dégager du temps de médicale le fait que
les médecins puissent prendre des
internes de façon un peu plus nombreuses
la coopération entre les professionnels
santé mais nous savons tous que ces
mesures s'inscrivent dans le temps long
c'est bien fort de ce constat que le
président de la république et la
première ministre ont créé une
délégation et ça ne vous a pas échappé
de l'organisation territoriale et des
professionnels de santé dont j'ai
l'honneur d'avoir la charge je vois bien
les enjeux qui sont les nôtres et cette
délégation par elle-même portent la
volonté de partage de co-construction
entre les élus locaux les territoires
les professionnels de santé c'est bien
dans ce sens que la feuille de route qui
est la mienne s'inscrit et que nous
serons ensemble force de proposition
avec les professionnels de santé avec
les territoires mais aussi avec vous et
que nous allons construire des solutions
qui pourront s'inscrire à rapidement et
apporter des solutions territoire par
territoire
c'est comme ça qu'on va y arriver je
vous remercie madame la ministre un la
parole est à monsieur thimoté ça
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
santé d'après le code de la santé
publique le droit fondamental à la
protection de la santé doit être mise en
oeuvre par tous moyens disponibles et
les autorités sanitaires contribuer à
garantir l'égal accès de chaque personne
aux soins pour autant 7 4 millions de
français vivent dans une commune d'
accès difficile aux soins fait aggravant
un généraliste sur deux a plus de 60 ans
et le nombre de médecins actifs
continuera à diminuer au moins jusqu'en
2030 mon département leur est dernier de
france avec 94 médecin pour 100000
habitants soit moitié moins que dans
d'autres départements l'offre de soins
dans certaines spécialités il est
inexistante nos concitoyens ils ont
trois solutions être soignés après des
mois d'attentes et souvent d'aggravation
de leur situation
tentez lorsqu'ils le peuvent d'obtenir
un suivi dans une région éloignée ou
comme 2 millions de français chaque
année renoncer aux soins avec des
conséquences parfois dramatiques
certes le numerus clausus dont
l'abrogation était demandé par notre
mouvement depuis 1988 a été
partiellement levée en 2021 mais les
conséquences de cette mesure mettront
encore des années à se faire ressentir
pendant ce temps la désertification
médicale continue de progresser il
s'agit d'un problème structurel qui
nécessite une réponse forte et rapide
ainsi envisagez-vous sans nuire à la
liberté d'installation de conditionner
le conventionnement de nouveaux médecins
dans les zones où l'offre de soins est
élevé de créer un dispositif dédié aux
zones sous denses pour favoriser la
présence d' internes en médecine
envisagez-vous comme le propose marine
le pen une rémunération de la
consultation modulée selon le lieu
d'installation sans différence de coût
pour le patient enfin proposez-vous
d'autres mesures concrètes permettant de
lutter efficacement contre le drame des
déserts médicaux
c'est une séance des cuvées spéciales
pour madame agnès firmin le bodo ça
s'appelle un ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé s'appelle jim à la
présidente madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député ou ça comme répondu précédemment
à la question posée par monsieur gare
aux sur la méthode je suis très clair et
le gouvernement est très claire les
mesures ont été prises lors du dernier
quinquennat elles s'inscrivent dans le
temps long et donc il y à bien urgence
et c'est bien pour ça je le dis et je le
redis que cette délégation
suite à la demande du président de la
république et de la première ministre a
été créé la délégation elle s'appelle
organisations territoriales et
professionnelles de santé c'est bien le
souhait qui est le nôtre de faire
travailler ensemble je dis bien ensemble
tous les élus tous les élus des
territoires pour apporter des réponses
parmi les propositions que vous avez
évoqué certaines sont déjà en
application et nous aurons l'occasion
d'en discuter si vous voulez tout à
l'heure mais dedans dans leur votre
département on constate un dynamisme du
département en matière d'exercice
coordonnées qui est une des réponses oui
aussi avec 23 maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires de ces pts effective
une troisième prévue pour la fin de
l'année deux centres de santé en région
normandie et dans l'eure en particulier
une nouvelle charte régionale d'accès
aux soins a été signé au mois de
décembre avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes dans leur enfin cette
dynamique est très suivie et des
dispositifs innovants sont soutenus dans
le cadre dans ce cadre par la rs en
coopération avec les acteurs du
département donc vous voyez bien
monsieur 7 monsieur le député cette
volonté elle est là nous savons bien que
toutes les solutions ne se prend pas
adapté à tous les territoires et c'est
bien territoire par territoire en
travaillant ensemble que nous allons
pouvoir répondre à la fois à la demande
des élus mais surtout apporter une
réponse à tous nos concitoyens je vous
remercie madame la ministre monsieur
1 puis d'accord sur le fait qu'on
construit beaucoup de santé dans notre
département mais aussi sur le fait que
beaucoup sont vides et qu'il va falloir
attirer des médecins pour les mettre
dans ces maisons de santé mais
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente sheikh membre
du gouvernement chers collègues alors
pour laisser un petit peu de répit à
madame le ministre firmin le bodo je
m'adresse monsieur christophe béchu
ministre la transition écologique et de
la cohésion des territoires
aujourd'hui 80 départements sont placées
en état d' alerte sécheresse et sont
concernés par des mesures de restriction
des usages de l'eau mon territoire haut
savoyard pourtant riche en eau est passé
ce vendredi 22 juillet en zone alerte
renforcée mais comme bon nombre de
territoires français plusieurs
associations nous alertent
quotidiennement sur les pénuries d'eau
mais aussi sur les dégradations de nos
milieux aquatiques des dizaines de
réservoirs d'eau sont vides des coupures
d'eau ont lieu régulièrement et les
allers retours des camions citernes sont
désormais incessants nos cours d'eau
sont largement impacté ce qui dérègle
profondément les écosystèmes présents je
salue le travail d'importance effectué
par le gouvernement depuis cinq ans les
assises de l'eau 2017 2018 ont notamment
permis une meilleure réactivité et une
meilleure harmonisation des politiques
de restriction de l'eau cependant ces
mesures exceptionnelles mais
symptomatique ne sont plus suffisantes
face aux épisodes de sécheresse plus
fréquents plus violent et plus précoces
le changement climatique modifie le
cycle de l'eau et nous en sommes
aujourd'hui les témoins directs quel
plan d'action votre ministère entend
qu'il menait ces prochaines années afin
d'anticiper mieux gérer nos ressources
en eau sur le long terme il est temps de
mener une réelle réflexion sur les
moyens et les outils permettant de
réduire nos consommations en eau de
façon pérenne et plus uniquement en
période de sécheresse comment
pouvons-nous renforcer notre politique
de prévention auprès de nos concitoyens
pour les sensibiliser aux gestes du
quotidien
de même la politique de l'eau en matière
de lutte contre la pollution ne doit pas
uniquement se limiter à des mesures de
surveillance de réparation mais doit
pouvoir mettre en place des mécanismes
de prévention sur le long terme en
changeant radicalement nos usages état
collectivités doivent être accompagnés
sur les différents systèmes de
récupération des eaux pluviales et eaux
grises
l'action monsieur ministre autres
ministères en temps utile mais n'est
plus le pour lutter plus efficacement et
plus durablement contre les épisodes de
sécheresse et de pérennisation merci
monsieur merci beaucoup la parole est à
monsieur christophe béchu nous ministres
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée violent merci
pour votre question
aujourd'hui 26 juillet nous avons
effectivement plus de 80 départements
qui sont concernés 90 pour être précis à
la minute où je vous parle 87 par au
moins un arrêté de restriction et trois
qui sont en situation de vigilance
avant de vous dire ce que nous allons
faire je veux revenir d'un mot vous
l'avez fait sur ce qui a été fait et
c'est pour moi l'occasion de saluer en
particulier l'action de celle qui m'a
précédé dans ce ministère je veux parler
de barbara pompili et des 100 millions
d'euros qui ont été allouées aux agences
de l'eau dans le cadre d'un plan de
résilience permettant en liaison avec
les assises de l'aude 2019 avec le var n
de lot de 2021 de s'interroger sur la
manière de rendre nos territoires plus
résilient
cette situation elle menace évidemment
les activités humaines vous l'avez dit
puisque la génération ou la
généralisation de la sécheresse oblige à
prendre des mesures qui sont des mesures
de restriction qui oblige à choisir
entre les usages mais elle menace aussi
nous le savons la biodiversité lutter
contre la sécheresse nous adapter aux
changements climatiques c'est donc bien
répondre à ces deux types d'enjeux les
mesures à prendre elles sont résolus la
première elle est contenue dans le zéro
artificialisation net et dans le fait de
conserver des espaces agricoles et
naturels en luttant contre
l'artificialisation qui ensuite renforce
les difficultés la deuxième elle vise à
faire en sorte de nous appuyer sur les
dispositifs de renaturation de d
imperméabilisation pour poids à
l'intérieur de nos territoires permettre
aussi des écoulements une gestion du
cycle de l'eau qu'ils soient plus
efficaces et je vous renvoie aux
annonces de la première ministre
elisabeth baume qui date d'il ya moins
d'un mois sur les 500 millions que
j'aurai l'occasion de présenter aux
mamans du plf enfin il nous faut plus
largement dans l'union des énergies avec
les collectivités territoriales
anticipez harmoniser et je n'ai plus de
temps
merci monsieur ministre
la parole est un monsieur jérôme legavre
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
94000 c'est le nombre de bacheliers qui
à ce jour et sans affectation dans
l'enseignement supérieur il faut y
ajouter ces dizaines de milliers qui se
retrouvent du fait de l'arbitraire de
parcours sup affecté dans une formation
qu'ils n'ont pas choisi et qui risque du
coup de tout lâcher il faut aussi agité
tout y ajouter tous ceux qui renoncent à
formuler des voeux 22000 l'an dernier
monsieur le ministre il y avait dans ce
pays une conquête démocratique
fondamental le droit pour tout bachelier
parce qu'ils étaient bacheliers et donc
détenteur du premier grade universitaire
d'accéder à la formation de son choix
dans l'enseignement supérieur
le gouvernement précédent à supprimer ce
droit d'un trait de plume monsieur le
ministre voire à 17 à 18 ans sont à
venir confié à l'arbitraire d'un
algorithme est une monstruosité mais il
n'ya pas que l'algorithme le fond de la
faire c'est que le gouvernement a décidé
d'expulser des dizaines de milliers de
jeunes de l'enseignement supérieur en ce
moment même la sélection se met en place
en master avec les mêmes conséquences
destructrices et il ya une logique à
tout cela affirmer revendiquer le 14
juillet dernier par le président macron
hubert c'est super faisant écho à tu
traverses la rue et tu trouveras un
boulot dans une société eut brisé ou la
masse de la jeunesse devrait être voué à
la précarité pas besoin de qualification
alors monsieur le ministre un pouvoir
qui condamne sa jeunesse est un pouvoir
qui se condamne lui-même et donc ces
questions quand allez vous décidez de
mettre fin cette aberration monstrueuse
qui est parcours sup quand rétablir et
vous le droit pour chaque bacheliers
d'accéder à la formation de son choix
dans l'enseignement supérieur
question inséparable de cette dernière
quand rétablir et vous le baccalauréat
national
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame sylvie retailleau
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
merci madame la présidente monsieur
madame les députés monsieur le député le
gars vous avez une ministre pour un
ministre mais comme nous travaillons
ensemble sur ce problème je me permets
de venir au banc pour vous répondre
alors d'abord soyons clairs si c'est
pour mettre au début en priorité les
conditions de vie les conditions des
étudiants et les conditions d'avenir
décès du dian nous sommes d'accord c'est
une priorité du gouvernement est une
volonté et si de ne laisser personne au
bout de bord du chemin mais par contre
c'est vrai monsieur le député si c'est
pour dire qu'il faut c'est peu mais ce
parcours sup là nous ne sont pas
d'accord alors pourquoi pourquoi parce
que d'abord parcours sub si vous le
prenez comme une plateforme comme un
outil ce qui l'est aussi ses 5 ans
d'expérience ces cinq ans de retour
d'expérience qui nous permet de
l'utiliser en amélioration continue
parcours sup il est basé sur des
principes essentiels et ses principes
essentiels c'est de laisser le dernier
mot à l'étudiant contrairement à ce que
l'on avait à apb le dernier mode choix à
l'étudiant avec un accompagnement fort
et cet accompagnement je voudrais dire
le deuxième chose c'est que parcours sub
c'est pas qu'une plateforme c'est pas
qu'un outil la coupe c'est un
accompagnement humain et je voudrais ici
profité de l'occasion pour remercier
fortement tous les enseignants du
secondaire tous les enseignants du
supérieur que les enseignants au niveau
du rectorat
passent leur temps avec engagement à
faire ce qui est important pour jour
comme pour tous c'est à dire l'avenir de
nos jeunes et je voudrais finir pas vous
dire que l'on colle ses algorithmes et
vous annoncez peut-être un scoop c'est
d'abord ses algorithmes sont publiques
aux niveaux nationaux et sur les
critères locaux vous pourrez trouver
aujourd'hui dix mille rapport publié sur
les critères nationaux sur la plateforme
parcours sud parce que oui je suis
d'accord avec vous la transparence
aidera l'orientation nos étudiants
tuyaux merci je vous remercie madame est
ministre
il n'avait qu'une seconde
n'avait pas tant nord une seconde je
remercie mes chers collègues de bien
écouter les réponses aux questions que
vous posez la parole est à monsieur
pierre morel à l'huissier merci madame
la présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre ces derniers jours le pays a
été confronté à des feux d'une taille
exceptionnelle combattue par nos sapeurs
pompiers auxquels je veux rendre hommage
mais aussi à tous les acteurs de la
société civile aux élus à des bénévoles
y compris des agriculteurs qui ont prêté
main forte
à quelques années j'avais réalisé un
rapport parlementaire en liaison avec
jean jacques urvoas au nom de la
commission des lois il s'agissait à
l'époque de la question la vétusté de la
base de sécurité civile de marignane
aujourd'hui déplacer à nîmes garons nous
avons été confrontés lors de cette
mission à une grève des pilotes de
canadair qui nous avaient interpellé sur
l'état de la flotte de la question
récurrente de la maintenance des
canadair et deux tracker je ne rentrerai
dans aucune polémique car je sais que
des efforts ont été faits ces dernières
années toutefois je souhaite que vous
puissiez précisé à la représentation
nationale l'état précis de la flotte
aujourd'hui disponibles tant dans des
camps canadair quand beechcraft mais
également un hélicoptère il me semble
que le moment est venu de faire un état
des lieux au besoin à travers une
mission parlementaire sur l'état de nos
moyens sur la maintenance qui coûte cher
et sur les besoins au-delà des
équipements j'attire votre attention sur
les moyens humains
dont disposent nos pays à travers les
deux cent cinquante mille pompiers nous
disposons peu ou prou 296 seize mille
pompiers volontaires or le volontariat
est en crise la durée d'engagement est
passé de 20 ans à 9 ans aujourd'hui nous
avons voté la loi matras voté à
l'unanimité mais elle ne règle pas
objectivement la situation du
volontariat député de la lozère
99% des pompiers sont des volontaires
nous avons des difficultés armes et les
bsa b et c le cas dans beaucoup de
départements ruraux sur ces deux aspects
je souhaite de votre part une réponse
concrète pour le devenir de notre modèle
de sécurité civile je vous remercie la
parole est à monsieur charles darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur et des autres
maires
merci mais la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur député
morel à l'huissier je sais que vous
connaissez très bien cette question pour
avoir été depuis très nombreuses fois
dans cet hémicycle un décor à porter ou
un des co créateur des avancées pour les
sapeurs pompiers je veux avec vous aussi
salué le député fabia battra ce qui a
beaucoup travaillé avec la majorité
présidentielle
et qui avec vous monsieur le député
avait contribué à donner des moyens très
importants 1 200 pompiers qui ont été
salués unanimement d'ailleurs dans cet
hémicycle et dans celui du sénat voulait
poser des questions précises je vais
vous répondre précisément sur l'état de
la flotte nous avons à partir de ce
matin à 8h du matin puisque vous me
posiez des questions et je doute que
quand je vois arriver nom du député
morel à l'huissier la question des
potiers sera évoquée sous les 12
canadair qui sont en disponibilité pour
d'autres pays 10 ce matin était prêt à
décoller deux est en maintenance et
seront sans doute réparé d'ici ce soir
ou demain matin ce que vous savez
maintenant ce fait en 24 heures sur 24
sur la base de nîmes side h5 sont
disponibles 1 est en maintenance 3 beach
3 sont disponibles dont vous voyez que
loin des chiffres de moitié de là près
de moitié de la flotte serait
non fonctionnel que si j y sont
totalement faux toutes les bases
d'hélicoptères sont ouvertes et tous les
hélicoptères les 35 ans de la sécurité
civile et de ce que l'on loue puisqu'on
lui aussi deux hélicoptères bombardiers
d'eau vous le savez sont évidemment
disponibles nous avons renouvelé
l'intégralité de nos beach nous sommes
en train de renouveler la tnt d'eau dash
et nous avons 24 années de parc en
moyenne de vieillissement de nos
canadair et nous avons pris l'engagement
le président de la république l'a fait
une nouvelle fois en gironde de
renouveler le problème des canadairs
vous le savez bien puisque c'est une
marque monsieur le député c'est que nous
n'avons pas d'usinés aujourd'hui de
fabrication de ses avions et donc nous
travaillons avec l'union européenne et
merci l'europe un grand merci à l'europe
pour relancer en européen c'est canadair
oui on peut dire merci à l'europe merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur qui est du g20
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
santé je voudrais revenir sur la
question de la vaccination dans le cadre
de la variole du singe plusieurs
réponses nous ont été apportées
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'il faut que
nous en précision la portée tout d'abord
la haute autorité de santé a fait des
recommandations très rapidement
d'ailleurs delvingt mais cela a été
souligné toutefois nous avons beaucoup
de remontées de nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner qui
aujourd'hui n'y arrive pas j'ai moi même
tenté ce matin d'obtenir un rendez-vous
pour tester l affaire est effectivement
le rendez vous n'est pas donné avant
trois semaines voire un mois ce qui est
incompatible avec les recommandations de
la haute autorité en qu'un de particules
en cas de nécessité de prophylaxie
post-exposition
deuxième point concerne les stocks
la question des stocks de vaccins est
évidemment fondamental y aurait un
million de stocks aux états unis les
allemands ont tachetée de 140 mille
doses vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
que le déstockage aurait lieu autant que
nécessaire mais ça ne répond pas à la
question du stock quel est le stock
aujourd'hui parce que cette question en
fait est aussi celle au-delà de la
variole du singe de la question de la
préparation du pays à une éventuelle
remontée de la variole sous la forme
d'une attaque terroriste en 2006 il y
avait un plan de préparation nationale
en cas de l'utilisation de la variole à
des fins terroristes et à l'époque en
2006 le plan national disposait que nous
avions 75 millions de doses alors je
vous pose la question madame la ministre
quel est l'état de notre stock
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame agnès firmin le
bodo ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
philippe juvin merci d'avoir rappelé que
dès les recommandations de la haute
autorité la france a été en capacité de
pouvoir vacciner et ce2 le 20 et le 24
mai merci d'avoir oublié de rappeler que
dès les recommandations de la has le 8
juillet dès le 11 juillet dès le 11
juillet les ars les ars étaient en
mesure de pouvoir développer la
vaccination je voulais dit tout à
l'heure
quarante deux mille doses ont déjà été
des stocks et le déstockage de ses doses
va se poursuivre dans les prochaines
semaines autant que nécessaire et je
vous le redis en fonction des demandes
remontées du terrain par les ars il faut
il faut les doses au bon endroit nous le
savons doses
nous le savons nous le savons ça nous
laisse nous le savons 50 % des
infections ont lieu en ile de france est
ce que vous dites vous nous reprochez
riez d'envoyer des doses là où il n'y a
pas de personnes infectées ou là où il
n'y a pas de demande donc les allées les
développements des d'eau se fait en
fonction des demandes des ars vous le
savez le délai parfois trop longs et
vous l'avez évoqué peuvent exister sur
certains territoires c'est notamment le
cas de l'île de france et c'est pour ça
que depuis hier le ministre françois
broad a annoncé l'ouverture aujourd'hui
d'un centre dans le xiiie arrondissement
donc vous le voyez monsieur le député
nous sommes actifs et proactif sur le
fait de pouvoir s'adapter au
développement de l'épidémie comme le
sommes depuis le début je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la ministre monsieur g 20
madame la ministre merci pour votre
réponse toutefois à la question très
précise combien de doses disposons-nous
je n'ai pas la réponse mais probablement
parce que je pense que c'est une
question très technique vous pouvez
apporter leurs réponses dans les
semaines qui viennent et la même manière
je souhaiterais que vous puissiez aussi
réfléchir à la question de s que nous
sommes aujourd'hui en capacité de
produire par exemple vaccin sur le
territoire national ou leur territoire
de l'union c'est aussi une question qui
font que nous puissions résoudre merci
[Musique]
la parole est à madame anna brunier
rares merci madame la présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche madame la ministre la
précarité étudiante est un sujet qui
nous importe nous les députés
renaissance c'est à la fois hélas une
réalité pour certains étudiants et une
crainte répandue auprès de nos jeunes et
le sujet a pris de l'ampleur et de la
visibilité avec la crise de lakovic 19
les dépenses de nos étudiants sont
particulièrement élevés lorsqu'ils des
cohabitent de chez leurs parents coût du
logement frais d'alimentation et de
transport sont leur premier poste de
dépense leurs revenus sont de trois
types l'aide familiale les aides de
l'état et parfois un revenu du travail
la crise de lakovic 19 les a
particulièrement éprouvés car nombre
d'entre eux ont perdu leur job étudiant
face à ces difficultés le gouvernement
et le parlement ont agi avec
détermination aide exceptionnelle
revalorisation des bourses prolongement
des contrats doctoraux renforcement des
prêts étudiants garantis par l'état
repas du crous à 1 euros gratuité des
protections périodiques et de la
contraception pour les moins de 26 ans
prise en charge et séances de psy
gratuite création de nouveaux emplois
étudiants sur les campus alors que nous
sortions de la crise sanitaire ils ont
été touchés aussi de plein fouet par
l'inflation face à cette situation nous
devons continuer à les soutenir et c'est
ce qu'a prévu le gouvernement aussi nous
nous réjouissons que des dispositions
soient prises à leur endroit dans les
mesures du pack de protection du pouvoir
d'achat madame la ministre pouvez vous
nous présenter les mesures générales de
protection du pouvoir d'achat dont
bénéficieront nos étudiants est
également des mesures spécifiques et
adaptées à leur situation qui vont être
déployés dernier point est un point
sensible le logement qui reste leur
premier poste de dépenses dans les
grandes villes comme à lyon dans ma
circonscription
la tension immobilière les loyers
pratiqués décourage certains jeunes de
poursuivre leurs études mais pire il
peut les conduire à la pauvreté voire au
surendettement aussi madame la ministre
vous pouvez vous nous indiquer la
stratégie et les ambitions du
gouvernement pour préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des étudiants et lutter contre
leur précarité je vous remercie je vous
remercie mes chers collègues la parole
est à madame sylvie retailleau ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci ma vraie présidente monsieur
mesdames les députés madame la députée
brugnara d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier d'avoir rappelé tout ce qui a
été fait pendant la crise qu vide où la
jeunesse et nos étudiants en particulier
ont été durement trash touché aussi bien
socialement que psychologiquement et
toutes les mesures qui ont été faites
par le gouvernement et soutenue au sein
aussi de cet hémicycle et je voudrais
vous en remercier aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement l'inflation et donc le
pouvoir d'achat qui touche nos étudiants
donc que je vais vous comme vous l'avez
demandé sur d'abord les mesures
d'urgence les mesures plus conjoncturels
que nous avait point nous avons prises
pour la rentrée donc tout d'abord une
revalorisation de 4% pour les bourses
étudiantes à la rentrée ensuite cette
aide exceptionnelle de solidarité 200
euros pour tous les étudiants boursiers
mais aussi parce que nous le savons et
vous l'avez dit les étudiants des
cohabitants les étudiants qui quittent
le nid de leurs parents et bien sont
durement touchés par la précarité dont
cette mesure touche aussi tous les
étudiants qui touchent l'apl je rappelle
aussi l'augmentation des 3,5 pour cent
pour la pl mais nous avons aussi
prolongé pour toute l'année
universitaire le ticket à 1 euro pour
tous les étudiants boursiers mais aussi
tous les étudiants précaires qui sont
identifiés par le crous qui s'est
aujourd'hui les identifier et puis le
gel des frais d'inscription et le gel
des loyers donc c'est un ensemble de
mesures conjoncturelles qui va venir
ensuite accompagné dès la rentrée je
vais lancer une concertation avec les
étudiants les établissements les crous
pour des mesures plus structurelles sur
les bourses pour les étudiants et aussi
vers versus la santé des étudiants
les logements alors comme vous avait
parlé de lyon il se trouve que voilà
c'était un sujet la semaine dernière
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'il y a
des grosses rénovations partout et en
particulier à lyon avec je crois à la
résidence françoise barré sinoussi et
350 nouveaux logements étudiants plus de
1300 à lyon logements rénovés donc ça ça
suit le plan de rénovation au niveau des
logements et de création mini merci
beaucoup la parole est un monsieur
yannick monnet
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué aux
transports monsieur le ministre la
semaine dernière les passagers du train
paris clairement ont vécu une nuit et
une journée de galère ils sont arrivés à
moulins dans ma circonscription puis à
clermont ferrand après près de vingt
heures de retard à cause d'une rupture
de caténaire c'est inacceptable c'est
d'autant plus inacceptable que celle
énième incident survenu sur cette ligne
sur laquelle se multiplient les
problèmes techniques qui pourrissent
littéralement la vie des usagers ces
incidents sont le témoin de graves
problèmes de maintenance du réseau et de
l'insuffisance chronique des moyens
alloués aux infrastructures qui restent
nettement inférieurs à ceux de nos
voisins européens est insuffisant par
rapport aux besoins ce constat a conduit
il y a deux semaines le pdg de la sncf
jean pierre farandou a réclamé un plan
d'investissement de 100 milliards
d'euros sur 15 ans dans le transport
ferroviaire et les infrastructures
afférentes comme le fond l'allemagne
l'italie ou la suisse
les cheminots mais aussi les ong
environnementales réclament depuis des
années un vrai plan d'investissement sur
dix ans pour construire l'efficacité du
réseau ferroviaire de 2030 favoriser un
développement juste et harmonieux des
territoires et répondre aux besoins et
aux attentes de la population et des
usagers les investissements actuels en
tenant compte des 4,75 milliards d'euros
du plan de relance sont largement
insuffisants pour tenir nos objectifs
climatiques et rebâtir un grand service
public ferroviaire ma question est donc
5 monsieur le ministre que quand ils
vous faire pour répondre à la colère des
usagers quels moyens entendez vous
mettre en oeuvre dans les prochains mois
pour moderniser et développer le réseau
douves est la part du fer du fret
ferroviaire dans le transport de
marchandises développer les lignes du
quotidien et faire que notre système
ferroviaire reste l'un des plus
performants au monde jour merci
merci la parole est à monsieur clément
bonne ministre des transports
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
yannick monnet vous posez en réalité
plusieurs questions je veux d'abord
réagir sur la question que vous avez
soulevé au début celle de l'incident qui
s'est produit de manière très
regrettable la semaine dernière sur les
paris clermont avec en effet plus de 20
heures d'attentes et je le dis très
sincèrement c'est une ligne qui est en
difficulté particulière qui mérite un
investissement particulier renforcé qui
je le souligne est engagé il a été
engagé il ya déjà quelques mois et
horizons 2026 ou le savez c'est
l'intégralité des rames qui sera
renouvelée et ses plus de 800 millions
qui sera investi aussi dans la remise à
niveau du réseau le devon sur cette
ligne en particulier j'ai d'ailleurs
échangé des samedis à cette demande avec
le maire de clermont monsieur bianchi
avec la députée being human j'ai pris
l'engagement je le ferai avec tous ceux
qui le souhaitent de faire la rentrée
une réunion sur ce sujet spécifique pour
que nous allions précisément les
modalités de réinvestissement sur cette
ligne vous poser une question plus
générale qui est celle de
l'investissement dans le ferroviaire
j'insiste sur la question du réseau elle
est une prise de conscience récente et
je veux saluer le travail qui a été
conduit par le gouvernement précédent
parce que personne ne voulait parler du
réseau et nous avons réinvesti très
massivement c'était un milliard d'euros
il ya seulement 15 ans 2 5 milliards
d'euros par an il ya cinq ans nous
sommes aujourd'hui à presque 3 milliards
d'euros de réinvestissement dans le
réseau pour éviter son vieillissement
nous continuerons cet effort la praire
ministre l'a dit devant votre assemblée
la colonne vertébrale de la mobilité
durable et verte c'est le ferroviaire
nous devons donc en effet donné la
priorité au réseau et nous le
continuerons nous aurons l'occasion d'en
discuter dans le prochain projet de loi
de finances dans la trajectoire
pluriannuelle dans le rapport du conseil
d'orientation des investissements qui a
commencé sous l'autorité de david
valence à produire son travail pour que
cette priorité soit matérialisée
accéléré financer je crois qu'il est
temps là partagé nous le ferons sur
cette ligne en particulier sur
l'ensemble des orientations dans les
prochaines semaines je tiens à signaler
que c'est des genres est déjà très
concret puisque le contrat de
performance qui pour la première fois
sur dix ans a été signé entre l'état et
sncf réseau consacre déjà ce montant de
3 milliards d'euros par an
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
lettre la parole est à monsieur iñaki et
shanice merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre de l'économie alors
que la saison touristique bat son plein
la communauté d'agglomération pays
basque a voté le 9 juillet à la
quasi-unanimité transpartisane le
principe de compensation qui contraindra
les propriétaires loin bien sûr harbi
nbi a proposé un logement équivalent
toute l'année cette mesure forte qui ait
soutenu je le précise par un exécutif
proche de votre sensibilité vise à
lutter contre la spéculation immobilière
qui frappe de plein fouet les communes
de zones tendues du pays basque et de
l'ensemble des façades littorales et qui
s'attaque désormais aux territoires
intérieurs comme les vallées béarnaises
selon l' agence d'urbanisme atlantique
et pyrénées les hébergements de tourisme
de conduire et augmenté de 130% entre
2016 et 2020 sont aujourd'hui plus de 16
mille logements au pays basque autant
d'habitations qui ne sont pas
accessibles aux habitants du territoire
par ailleurs depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire le prix du mètre carré a
augmenté de 15 à 20% ce qui rend
impossible accession à la propriété pour
les habitants du territoire qui je le
rappelle le font vivre à l'année
aujourd'hui sur les façades littorales
les banques de suivre les dossiers
d'emprunt que pour du locatif
touristique car la fiscalité est plus
rentable sur les meublés de tourisme que
sur la location longue durée pas
possible de louer pas possible d'acheter
le parco immobilier de mon territoire et
de tout le littoral atlantique est
aujourd'hui sous l'emprise de
spéculateurs qui accumule les biens
immobiliers et qui vivent uniquement de
leur ronde même si le tourisme est un
facteur de développement force est de
constater qu'aujourd'hui cela peut
engendrer des situations intenables pour
nos concitoyens le pays basque que vous
connaissez bien n'est ni un hôtel d'une
plateforme boursière de nombreux sassus
associations et élus locaux et société
civile se mobilisent car il s'agit d'une
véritable fracture sociale qui vise en
premier lieu les jeunes les plus
précaires et les classes moyennes
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il est urgent
que notre assemblée se mobilise pour
apporter des réponses législatives à
cette problématique qui touche bon
nombre de notre circonscription de
donner des véritables leviers à nos
collectivités en ce sens monsieur le
ministre quels sont vos positions sur
une évolution fiscal des meublés de
tourisme sur le déplafonnement de la
surtaxe d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires et sur l'encadrement des
loyers je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur olivier klein
le ministre délégué chargé de la ville
et du logement
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député chinese
alors sur votre question qu'ils posent
une problématique particulière du
logement dans l'est dans les zones
touristiques bien évidemment la question
du logement se pose au sens large dans
ce pays et vous le savez il est
important pour nous et c'est la volonté
de la première ministre de construire
pour l'ensemble des habitants un
parcours résidentiel la question du
zonage la question de la fiscalité est
une question sur lequel nous avons
décidé de nous pencher de manière
extrêmement important parce que vous
avez raison il n'est pas possible que
dans certaines zones un certain nombre
de spéculateurs achètent profite
d'outils spéculatifs et en profite et ne
met pas ces logements à la location et
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous allons
travailler d'arrache-pied dans l'est
dans les mois qui viennent pour le reste
je je crois espérait être le ministre du
parcours résidentiel la question qui se
pose c'est à chaque étape de sa vie
qu'elle logement nous sommes capables de
proposer aux habitants de de ce pays et
nous allons y réfléchir à travers
l'ensemble des dispositifs si j'ose dire
de la sortie de l'hébergement avec avec
logement d'abord ensuite la production
et la production extrêmement massive de
logements de logements sociaux j'étais
encore hier après midi et avec
christophe robert puis avec et mac os
pour reparler au monde du logement de
nos de la stratégie et suivant la
volonté de madame la première ministre
de bâtir un plan de de confiance un
nouveau pacte de confiance avec le monde
hlm et nous y travaillons et j'étais
hier matin avec le patron de la
fédération française du bâtiment pour
réfléchir aussi avec l'ensemble du monde
immobilier à la production donc c'est
tous ces chantiers qui sont devant nous
bien évidemment je n'oublie pas votre
question et la question du littoral mais
nous travaillons à l'ensemble de ces
chantiers dans les mois qui viennent et
dès la rentrée notamment lors du congrès
hlm nous aurons déjà ensemble de
propositions nouvelles affaires merci je
vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame virginie duby
muller
si madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées depuis
plusieurs années maintenant les
directeurs d'ehpad font face à une grave
pénurie de personnel pour effectuer leur
mission de soins et des couteaux prêts
des résidents dans des conditions
optimales un ehpad devrait compter un
personnel pour une personne âgée en
perte d'autonomie sera jsio est
aujourd'hui de 0,6 pour un entraînant un
profond mal-être des soignants et des
familles bien insuffisants au regard des
besoins en effet le personnel soignant
doit faire face à une surcharge de
travail qui impactent la qualité des
soins apportés aux personnes âgées le
manque d'effectifs suffisants se traduit
par une détérioration des conditions
d'accueil au point que certains
résidents sont douchées que tous les
quinze jours dans certains
établissements les directeurs en sont à
demander de l'aide aux familles pour
donner les repas ou effectuer les
toilettes comment vieillir dignement
dans de telles conditions et pourtant le
personnel des ehpad multiplient les
heures supplémentaires patients d'un
patient à l'autre à une vitesse qui a
dans ses relances ont même à prendre des
congés faute de remplaçant à bout de
souffle épuisés moralement et
physiquement par la dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail de plus en plus de
soignants sont en arrêt maladie ou
choisissent de démissionner ce
diagnostic nous le connaissons vous le
connaissez monsieur le ministre j'ai
d'ailleurs publié dimanche une tribune à
ce sujet avec le professeur jules vingt
et une quarantaine de collègues
monsieur le ministre en cette période
estivale la pénurie de personnel dans
les ehpad va encore s'aggraver aussi
quelle thérapeutique envisagez vous de
mettre en oeuvre pour revaloriser les
conditions de travail des soignants dans
les ehpad et ainsi permettre à nos aînés
de vieillir dignement quand allons-nous
enfin débattre d'une loi sur la
dépendance qui devait être un des plus
grands sujets du précédent quinquennat
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole et à monsieur
jean christophe pons ministre des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
d'ubs muller vous le savez la période
estivale exacerbe certaines des
difficultés que nous rencontrons dans
les établissements mais aussi à domicile
dans le dans le domaine du grand âge la
question des tensions de personnel en
particulier
est révélée duran duran duran l'été et
je suis pour ma part déterminée à uvrer
pour ces professionnels dont je mesure
les attentes et jose dont je salue
également l'engagement j'avais
d'ailleurs annoncé dès mes premiers
jours après ma nomination un plan
d'urgence pour cet été pour les et pour
les ehpad notamment en mobilisant les
agences régionales de santé pour
renforcer le recrutement dans les ehpad
mais également pour mobiliser les
filière gériatrique sur les territoires
et assurer la continuité de la prise en
charge médicale des patients il ya aussi
un enjeu d'attractivité et je dois
souligner que si beaucoup a été fait
déjà grâce aux c'est dur notamment en
termes de revalorisations salariales
mais également en termes de mobilisation
de l'immobilier beaucoup restent
malheureusement à faire et c'est une
urgence et une priorité pour nous
aujourd'hui restaurer l'attractivité
dans les ehpad c'est les rendre et
renforcer la médicalisation de ces ehpad
c'est pourquoi nous avons pour objectif
de recruter plus de cinquante mille
professionnels aides soignants et
infirmiers diplômés d'état d'ici à 2027
de rendre ces ehpad aussi plus humains
en les ouvrant sur l'extérieur sur les
territoires à l'encontre en allant à
l'encontre de certains clichés qui sont
vides q les aujourd'hui madame la
députée vous appelait aussi à l'action
afin que nos aînés puisse vieillir dans
la dignité qu'ils méritent je n'ai pas
un mot à changer à ce programme et j'y
consacrerai toute mon énergie notamment
pour répondre à l'attenté des français
puisque 90% d'entre eux aujourd'hui
souhaitent vieillir à domicile ce sera
l'objet de la mobilisation de ma prime à
table de façon massive merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame marina ferrari
merci madame la présidente cette
question s'adresse à monsieur clément
bonne ministre des transports nous nous
apprêtons examiner la ratification du
traité france italie pour une
coopération bilatérale renforcée dit
traiter du quirinal qui a pour ambition
de développer nos relations avec nos
voisins transalpins sur de nombreuses de
nombreuses questions très importantes
pour nos deux pays s'il est un chantier
qui à lui seul illustre cette
coopération c'est celui du lyon-turin
infrastructures majeures de portée
écologique économique et humaine vous le
savez notre gouvernement doit se
positionner d'ici l'automne sur la
question des accès au tunnel de base en
2019 madame la première ministre alors
en charge des transports après une
décision permettant de relancer le
travail de concertation des territoires
afin de choisir le scénario pour les
accès français le comité de pilotage
ainsi retenu l'hypothèse grands gabarits
parfaitement cohérente avec les
objectifs de la transition écologique
puisqu'elle permettrait de passer sur le
ferroviaire les trois quarts des plus de
40 millions de tonnes de fret routier
qui traverse les alpes initialement
prévu pour mars 2022 la décision
française du fait du contexte
international a été repoussée pour
autant l'europe s'inquiète fortement de
l'absence d'une décision de notre part
qui met en risque la pérennité du
financement des accès et pourrait
conduire à repousser les financements
européens après 2027 bloquant également
les financements pour les accès du côté
italien ce point pourrait discréditer
notre parole dans ce dossier sans une
action rapide de votre part votre
décision doit donc intervenir au plus
vite afin de sécuriser les financements
européens mais surtout pour donner
aucune perspective pour nos vallées qui
attendent avec impatience de mieux
respirer et d'assurer ainsi une
meilleure protection du massif alpin et
une amélioration des mobilités entre
deux villes motrices en europe lyon et
turin ma question est donc simple
monsieur le ministre la france sera t
elle au rendez vous de ces décisions sur
les accès français au tunnel de base du
lyon turin avant cet hiver comme nous
nous étions engagés je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur clément bonne
ministre chargé des transports
madame la madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée ferrari vous avez raison à la
fois sur l'urgence du calendrier sur
l'importance de ce projet je tiens à
rappeler rapidement les étapes que vous
avez cités parce que nous en avons
beaucoup parlé de ce projet lyon turin
il est essentiel vous l'avez dit sur le
plan écologique économique humain
européen et il est enfin une réalité
puisque ce qui relie la france et
l'italie a fait l'objet d'engagements
matérialiser ensuite par des
financements rapide au moment du traité
du coût final c'était attendu depuis de
longues années et la décision qui a été
prise en 2019 qui est une excellente
décision a permis de lancer aussi la
concertation sur l'autre question celle
des accès nous avançons je tiens à vous
dire que sur ce qui a déjà été actée
nous aurons année après année des le plf
2023 les financements prioritaires
nécessaire pour que ce projet avance je
le précise parce que ça longtemps était
un projet qui a été victime d' aller
retour politique et des retours
budgétaire nous en avons besoin
impérativement quant à la question
complémentaire que vous évoquez elle est
évidemment essentiel vous avez rappelé
les raisons du décalage de calendrier je
m'en suis saisi avec christophe béchu de
manière prioritaire et nous aurons avec
vous une concertation à la rentrée pour
que nous puissions prendre les décisions
le comité de pilotage qui est
aujourd'hui sous l'égide du préfet de la
région auvergne rhône alpes vous a réuni
et je sais très bien quelle est l'option
que la plupart des élus dont vous-même
avaient étaient là avaient fait l'objet
avait annoncé la priorité c'est celle
qui permet la plus grande capacité de
fret et le gabarit pardon ferroviaire et
nous y travaillons je dois dire aussi
pour qu'on soit en vérité en
responsabilité que c'est l'option la
plus coûteuse et que toutes les parties
prenantes collectivités comme l'état qui
sont nécessairement engagés doivent en
mesurer les coûts et chacun doit les
assumer sinon nous ne ferions que
refaire les erreurs du passé a annoncé
des projets que nous serions pas ensuite
honoré c'est pour ça que je veux finir
avec vous ce travail de concertation que
nous devons mesurer toutes les
conséquences et en sécuriser le cas
échéant vous l'avez rappelé aussi les
financements européens qui sont
indispensables à la 11è de ce projet
pour les l'ordre de grandeur nous
parlons au total d'un montant de 15
milliards d'euros donc il est nécessaire
que cette responsabilités soient
partagées à fumer est décidée dans les
prochains mois merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à monsieur hubert julien
laferrière
merci malin présidente madame la miss
d'europe et des affaires étrangères à
chaque début de mandat à l'exécutif nous
promet de rompre avec la françafrique
est aujourd'hui président de la
république entame une tournée dans trois
pays africains pour je cite renouveler
la relation de la france avec le
continent ces mots il les employaient
déjà en 2010 est à ouagadougou et depuis
il ya eu le soutien de la france au
troisième mandat inconstitutionnel
d'alassane ouattara en côte d'ivoire
comme d'alpha condé en guinée
l'adoubement du nouveau président
tchadien mahamat débit qui a succédé à
son père sans processus électoral demain
le président emmanuel macron sera
accueilli au bénin par le président
patrice talon un pays autrefois salué
pour être le laboratoire de la
démocratie en afrique et qui désormais
connaît une situation des opposants
politiques alarmante reckya madougou s
garde des sceaux joël avio
constitutionnaliste reconnu condamné en
moins de 24 heures de procès à 20 ans et
dix ans de prison et détenu depuis un an
et demi dans des conditions totalement
indigne
leur tort serait utile d'avoir été
candidat à la présidence de la
république d'autres ont été contraints à
l'exil tels l'ex maire de cotonou léhady
soglo
avec près de 80 députés nous venons donc
d'adresser un courrier au président de
la république pour l'alerter sur la
situation béninoise manama mildt alors
que l' influence d'autres puissances
grandissent au continent comment passer
de la parole aux actes quant à la
construction d'une nouvelle relation
avec l'afrique à la fois solidaire
exigeante et porteuse d'espoir je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole et à madame
laurence bono ministre chargé de
l'europe hommes
merci madame la présidente
1 messieurs et mesdames les députés et
monsieur le député julien laferrière je
crois que je vais rectifier et complétée
peut-être un certaines de vos remarques
oui le président de la république il est
est au cameroun au bénin puis en guinée
bissau et jusqu'au jeudi 28 juillet 2022
et il s'agit après sa visite en roumanie
en moldavie et en ukraine du deuxième
grand déplacement international ce qui
confirme la priorité donnée au
partenariat euro africain dans la
politique étrangère du chef de l'état et
soit on s'engage soit on regarde cette
visite elle intervient dans le droit fil
de l'agenda présenté en novembre pour
renouveler la relation afrique-france
mettre à l'honneur les liens humains et
historiques entre la france et le
continent
ce sera l'occasion pour le chef de
l'état de se placer une nouvelle fois à
l'ecoute des jeunesses africaines et
françaises est de mettre à l'honneur
l'art les culture et le patrimoine du
continent
ce déplacement s'inscrit également dans
un contexte régional et international
difficile
la menace terroriste présente depuis
plusieurs années au sahel continuent de
se propager dans le golfe de guinée ce à
quoi la france a réagi en adoptant son
dispositif sécuritaire
et vous l'avez noté les conséquences de
la guerre en ukraine se font également
fortement ressentir sur le continent
africain très départ très dépendant des
importations de produits agricoles ne
tombons pas dans le narratif de la
russie le déplacement va donc être
l'occasion de mettre l'accent sur
l'impulsion permis par l'initiative farm
elle a été lancée par le président en
mars dernier vous en souvenez pour
renforcer notre résilience collective
face aux crises alimentaire et favoriser
l'investissement de long terme dans
l'agriculture dans les pays vulnérables
et notamment en afrique je vous remercie
et madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur julien
laferrière merci ministre évidemment les
enjeux géopolitiques de cette visite
sont importants mais j'espère en tout
cas que demain le président la
république sera fidèle à cette place
singulière qu'occupe la france patrie
des droits humains sur la scène
internationale et qui parlera donc au
président talons de la situation des
prisonniers politiques dans son pays et
en particulier de madame madougou et
monsieur a mis au jour merci
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique de la cohésion du
territoire monsieur le ministre la
semaine dernière de nombreux français
ont senti des odeurs de fumée un peu
partout en france en raison des
terribles incendies en gironde mais
aussi dans d'autres régions de france
nombre de nos concitoyens se sont alors
inquiétés de la qualité de l'air qu'ils
respirent et et c'est pour cette raison
qu'en tant que président du conseil
national de l'air je souhaitais aborder
ce sujet d'actualité devant la
représentation nationale
le panache de ces incendies a en effet
balayé une grande partie du territoire
national qui au delà de la gêne
olfactive a causé d'importantes hausses
des niveaux de pollution aux particules
fines générés par les feux cet épisode
de pollution et fort heureusement resté
relativement bref sur la majeure partie
du territoire et s'est donc avérée
globalement peu impactant pour la santé
nos concitoyens toutefois dans les
département voisin de la gironde par
exemple la pollution aux particules
fines atteint des niveaux plus
préoccupante et ce sur plusieurs jours
cette situation a conduit à prendre des
mesures d'urgence pour protéger la santé
respiratoire des habitants l'agencé
régionale de santé a notamment diffusé
une série de recommandations sur les
gestes à adopter néanmoins après
échanges avec les associations agréées
par l'état pour la surveillance de la
qualité de l'air que je salue pour la
qualité de leur travail il apparaît que
certaines mesures d'urgence de
protection des populations n'ont été
déclenchée que lorsque la pollution a
été mesurée par les capteurs situés à
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres des
feux et non dès le début des incendies
aussi monsieur le ministre à l'avenir ne
serait-il pas plus pertinent en cas de
grand incendie de mettre en place et par
défaut des mesures d'urgence des
l'aggravation de l'un s'en disent en
attendre le dépassement des seuils
réglementaires soient mesurés avait
plusieurs dizaines d'heures de décalage
plus généralement monsieur le ministre
quel e nouvelles mesures d'urgence pour
nous selon vous envisagé à l'avenir pour
aller dans le sens d'une meilleure
protection de nos concitoyens face à de
tels épisodes de pollution liée aux
incendies vous remercie la parole et à
monsieur christophe béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la présidente madame la première
miss mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le président fuji
27 1400 hectares dont 20000
effectivement pour le seul département
de la gironde est avec vous l'avais dit
au delà du courage des sapeurs pompiers
qui a été rappelé encore dans cette
enceinte tout à l'heure par le ministre
de l'intérieur
l'équivalent d'un pic de pollution
générée par les particules fines dans le
sillage des fumées d'incendié
cet
épisode de pollution a donné lieu du 21
au 23 juillet dans le département de la
gironde et dans les parlements des
landes à des niveaux de particules pm10
et pm2 5 vous connaissez par coeur
dépassant les seuils d'alert mais dès le
19 juillet la préfète de la gironde
avait émis une alerte et à compter du 21
elle a pris des mesures
vous avez cité la rs pourtant je pense
qu'il faut élargir le propos et c'est
autant aux députés co président du
conseil national de l'air que je
m'adresse plus largement le retour
d'expérience de ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre
nous devons l'avoir d'abord sur ce sujet
dans le sillage de la mission
d'information qui est conduite par deux
commissions du sénat sur ce qu'on
appelle avec des guillemets des
méga-feux mais sur la manière dont face
à des épisodes d'une exceptionnelle en
pleurs on adapte à la fois nos
dispositifs mais aussi en amont c'est
débroussaillage c'est les couloirs d'un
110c les dispositifs de prévention
pendant ou avec les fêtes décalage que
vous pointez pour qu'on ait des réflexes
en termes de d'alert et puis après et ça
ce sera au coeur du déplacement que je
ferai demain avec marc fesneau pour
aller regarder aussi comment on replante
comment on tient compte une fois que le
feu est passé de la capacité à régénérer
une partie des espaces parce que c'est
bien toute cette chaîne qui aujourd'hui
nous interrogent et nous questionnent
dans le cadre du réchauffement
climatique et la multiplication de ces
événements ne doutez pas de notre
détermination et notre volonté de vous y
associer merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur pierrick
bertolo
bercement la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur marc
fesneau ministre l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais évoqué la
situation de catastrophique des éleveurs
de porcs en france en particulier ceux
de ma circonscription dans les flandres
ce territoire a perdu les deux tiers de
ces exploitations en 30 ans
celles qui subsistent sont au bord de
l'asphyxié et le doivent souvent le sol
leur survie qu'à la polyculture le
marché du porc breton est confronté à la
concurrence déloyale d'autres pays
européens ce qui a pour conséquence un
prix de ventes insuffisant pour
permettre aux exploitants de vivre
dignement de leur travail à titre
d'exemple un éleveur d'une centaine de
porcs de débourser 3500 euros par
semaine pour faire fonctionner
correctement son exploitation dans un
contexte d'explosion des coûts de
production
cette situation inédite inquiète à juste
titre les exploitants mais aussi leurs
banques qui hésitent à continuer à les
soutenir c'est un cercle vicieux qui
fait craindre la disparition pure et
simple des exploitations porcines en
flandre
laloë galim voter en 2018 et galim de en
2021 malgré quelques avancées ne permet
toujours pas de garantir des prix
rémunérateurs
par exemple elle n'inclut pas
d'obligation de transparence entre tous
les acteurs de la filière de plus la loi
de modernisation de l'économie de 2008
qui régit les trois-quarts de
l'agroalimentaire a un effet dévastateur
car elle prime sur la loi et galim et
certaines enseignes de grande
distribution en profite
monsieur le ministre les acteurs de la
filière porcine veulent vivre de leur
métier en ne subissant plus une
concurrence étrangère déloyale il
souhaite aussi l'interdiction de la
vente à perte ainsi qu'une définition de
la taille critique des élevages afin de
s'assurer de leur rentabilité
quelles réponses comptez vous apporter à
ces revendications et à la détresse des
éleveurs pour ça je vous remercie
vous remercie la parole est à m e marc
fesneau ministre de l'agriculture et la
souveraineté alimentaire
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
député-maire tholot merci de cette
question qui me permet de faire le point
sur la crise de la filière porcine qui a
démarré automne en l'automne et de
l'hiver dernier qui est le l'effet
cumulatif d'une baisse des prix et d'une
hausse des charges pour les éleveurs est
à la fois dans votre département mais
évidemment dans toute la france pour
vous dire aussi que le gouvernement
s'est attelé à la tâche dès le mois de
janvier dernier avec un plan de 270
millions d'euros un plan d'urgence pour
réagir à cette crise et qui est saluée
d'ailleurs pour la filière comme un plan
qui a permis d'éviter ce que vous
craignez à juste titre qu'un certain
nombre d'élevages ferme alors cédé plan
qui vise à apporter des aides d'urgence
15000 euros par exploitant ses plus de
trois mille exploitants qui ont été
concernés un plan aussi à la
structuration j'y reviendrai juste après
dans le cadre d'une contractualisation
avec et galim et puis un plan pour la
prise en charge des cotisations sur
l'autre sociale dernier élément nous
travaillons aussi avec le réseau
bancaire vous avez raison pour faire en
sorte qu'on allège les charges et que le
réseau bancaire prendre prenne sa part
et fasse par un étalement de dettes les
disponibles mettent en place les
dispositions nécessaires pour que les
éleveurs puissent y faire face j ajoute
enfin ça c'est après la crise et
craignent un qui a démarré au mois de
février dernier à une aide de 400
membres d'un demi milliard environ
toutes filières animales confondues mais
donc aussi la filière porcine porcine
pour alléger les charges en alimentation
animale et qui est fort utile on est en
train de délivrer si vous me permettez
cette expression les aides aux
agriculteurs et aux éleveurs en
particulier l'aide à partir de cette
semaine et puis tout ça nécessite aussi
des éléments plus structurelle ça c'est
la gestion de crise des éléments
structurels c'est un de faire appliquer
et galim ça nécessite sans doute dans la
filière plus de contractualisation nous
veillons chaque semaine avec mon
collègue lescure et macaulay grégoire à
faire en sorte que dans les négociations
commerciales qui est bien la
transparence et que la valeur ajoutée
soit bien réparti ce tout au long de la
chaîne mais il faut y veiller en
permanence le deuxième élément c'est de
stimuler la demande et donc on aura des
actions de communication pour valoriser
la viande porcine
la charcuterie c'est un élément
important enfin le troisième c'est
l'amélioration des débouchés export
parce que nous sommes une filière qui
est très exportatrice et les efforts du
gouvernement payer pour aller notamment
vers les pays asiatiques 12 voiliers en
état à l'oeuvre il ya une feuille de
route qui est tracée avec la filière
porcine que je remercie beaucoup de son
travail et je pense que dans les mois
qui viennent on voit que le marché est
en train de se relever un peu dans les
mois qui viennent si merci beaucoup la
parole est à monsieur françois géré
digoin
merci madame la présidente madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur marc fesneau ministre de
l'agriculture
l'agriculture française est au coeur de
ce qui fait notre identité nous devons
en être fiers elle nous nourrit elle est
un marqueur de nos paysages et un
formidable atout économique pour le pays
les agriculteurs ont toujours tenu une
place particulière dans notre société
dans le département du maine-et-loire
près de 20 % des agriculteurs vont
partir à la retraite dans les cinq
années qui viennent
entre 2011 et 2010 9 seuls trois
agriculteurs sortant sur cinq ont été
remplacés dans la région pays de loire
c'est le cas dans la majorité des
départements
en 2030 48% des chefs d'exploitation
auront atteint l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
s'impose pour plusieurs raisons
notamment trois
relocaliser notre alimentation
décarbonés notre économie sécuriser
notre autonomie alimentaire
les agriculteurs cessent leur activité
après plusieurs décennies
d'investissements financiers et humains
leur outil de travail et leur patrimoine
mérite d'être valorisé
monsieur le ministre je sais qu'avec le
gouvernement vous êtes engagés sur ce
sujet en septembre dernier le président
de la république a annoncé aux jeunes
agriculteurs la création d'un fonds
système de portage pour le foncier
agricole
ainsi ma question est la suivante
à l'instar des opci qui soutiennent le
développement économique quel dispositif
l'état envisage de mettre en place ou
déployés afin de faciliter le
financement des reprises d'exploitations
notamment le rachat du matériel du
cheptel du foncier bâti et non bâti pour
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
merci la parole est à monsieur marc
fesneau ministre de l'agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
merci de votre question sur les
questions d'installation vous l'avez
souligné dans dix ans plus de 60 % des
agriculteurs pourront partir à la tête
et probablement partiront-ils à la
retraite et donc c'est un défi majeur
c'est un défi pour l'agriculture et les
agriculteurs c'est un défi pour notre
territoire et c'est un défi de
souveraineté c'est d'ailleurs dans ce
sens que le président de la république
et la première ministre dans sa
déclaration de politique générale a
réaffirmé la volonté du gouvernement
en 2023 de déposer un texte de loi qui
devra être un texte d'orientation et
d'avenir pour notre agriculture avec
différents dispositifs nous permettrait
d'être rapide mais le dise tu es les
différents sujets que nous avons à
travailler les sujets de cession et
transmission et dans la session la
session la question pour un certain
nombre de structures du portage
financier parce qu'on voit bien que ça
peut être un frein et chez le sait dans
la capacité à se préparer parce que
quand la cession n'est pas préparé on
voit bien que l'installation est plus
difficile deuxièmement c'est la capacité
à la fois attirer des jeunes qui
viennent du milieu agricole et puis des
jeunes des moins jeunes d'ailleurs
qu'ils viennent hors du milieu agricole
parce que ça ça paraît un élément
important deuxième sujet c'est la
formation on a un système d'enseignement
agricole qui est remarquable et que
beaucoup de pays reconnaissent comme
exceptionnelle il faut continuer à le
conforter y compris dans les grandes
transitions qu'ils essaient de de faire
apprendre aux jeunes les transition
écologique les transitions énergétiques
et donc c'est les sujets majeurs sur
lequel nous devons travailler sur
lesquels nous allons travailler
troisième point c'est l'âge l'innovation
et la recherche il n'y aura pas de
capacité à l'agriculture à faire face
aux défis qui sont les nôtres sans
innovation et son recherche et donc ça
c'est un point important que nous
devrons posé sur la table dernier point
c'est la question de l'investissement
dans le cadre du plan de françois
hollande dans le cadre de france 2030 la
première ministre l'a rappelé il ya un
certain nombre d'actions qui ont été
prévus je parle de france de 80 pour
favoriser l'investissement dans
l'agriculture parce que sans cet
investissement les agriculteurs se
retrouveront dans une impasse et puis le
dernier point par dont j'ai oublié et
c'est en fait le plus important il n'y
aura pas de capacité à transmettre les
exploitations agricoles s'il n'y a pas
de revenus et donc nous devons continuer
à travailler on a parlé tout à l'heure
sur la question des gars ligne sur le
revenu des agriculteurs pour leur
permettre à permettre à des jeunes
d'avoir une perspective de moyen long
terme sinon ils n'auraient ils
n'arriveront pas à s'installer donc
c'est les enjeux que nous avons devant
nous je vous remercie
si monsieur le ministre pour la dernière
question de l'après midi madame nathalie
claude yole
merci merci madame la présidente pour
effectuer un trajet en train depuis
montpellier vers paris il faut compter
entre 50 euros pour les trains les plus
matinaux et 150 euros jusqu'à 180 euros
en période estivale selon les périodes
les horaires et les compagnies cela peut
souvent revenir moins cher de faire ce
voyage en avion en allemagne un ticket
unique à 9 euros par mois a été mis en
place et il permet d'emprunter les
trains régionaux les tram les bus les
métros et les ferries autre exemple
l'espagne qui a décidé de rendre des
billets de train gratuits à partir du
1er septembre en espagne comme en
allemagne cette gratuité ou quasi
gratuité est d'abord présenté comme une
mesure de lutte contre l'inflation
devant l'explosion du prix de l'essence
nombreuses sont les personnes qui
rencontrent des difficultés pour se
rendre sur leur lieu de travail
nombreuses sont les familles notamment
dans les milieux les plus défavorisés
qui ne partent pas en vacances le
deuxième argument est celui de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique alors
que les températures sont de plus en
plus élevés inciter les gens à prendre
le train dans l'empreinte carbone est la
plus basse relève du bon sens
mais voilà le coût des billets de train
ne cesse d'augmenter l'insee souligné en
mai dernier une augmentation de plus de
15% par rapport à 2021 l'autorité de
régulation des transports calcul que le
prix moyen du tgv au kilomètre est deux
fois supérieur à celui d'un avion low
cost nos voisins eux ont compris que
l'investissement dans le transport
ferroviaire est une solution efficace
pour tout le monde ou qu'on habite quel
que soit son revenu comment se fait-il
alors qu'en france pays du ferroviaire
du service public et inventeur du tgv
nous ne soyons pas en mesure de mettre
en place un tel plan d'envergure
à quand la gratuité des transports en
commun
emmanuel matra promis qu'il mettrait en
place la planification écologique nous
attendons
je vous remercie
la parole est un autre élément ball
ministre des transports
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
nathalie oziol vous avez raison de
soutenir l'important du ferroviaire et
la qualité de notre service public
ferroviaire j'en suis très fier je
défendrai toujours mais il ne faut pas
de démagogie en la matière nous sommes
un grand pays du ferroviaire et de
l'investissement dans le ferroviaire
nous sommes le pays aujourd'hui en
europe où l'usager au total payent le
moins dans la prise en charge totale du
coup du ferroviaire vous avez parlé en
effet de coûts élevés sur le tgv nous
pourrons y revenir sur le pic de
vacances mais il est très important et
nous en avons fait une priorité je la
subis six coeurs et placements du
quotidien les trains du quotidien c'est
là on doit mettre l'essentiel de
l'investissement public dans les années
qui viennent nous allons parler du
réseau vous avez souligné à juste raison
la stde réinvestir nous devons choisir
des priorités nous devrons réinvestir
dans les transports des grandes
métropoles nous le ferons nous devrons
travailler parce que c'est pas un sujet
qui ne concerne que l'état mais aussi
les collectivités locales vous ne
manquerez pas de vérifier lieu par lieu
ville par ville les politiques de
gratuité qui sont mises en place par vos
amis politiques elles ne sont pas
systématiques loin de là et je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est à juste titre qu'il
faut faire participer l'usagé
modestement au coût des transports mais
nous avons besoin de réinvestir nous
avons besoin de réinvestir nos
transports du quotidien nous
travaillerons aussi bien sûr avec la
sncf sur les questions de tarification
je tiens à préciser qu'aujourd'hui c'est
néanmoins même dans les périodes
estivales même dans les périodes
chargées même sur les d'un grande
vitesse trois quarts des billets qui
font l'objet de cartes de réduction et
de réductions nous pouvons faire mieux
mais j'assume que nous devrons avoir des
priorités parce que nous devrons choisir
d'investir dans le réseau dans les
trains du quotidien dans les services
publics métropolitain nous le ferons
avec les collectivités locales dans les
années qui viennent
madame au viol
jusqu'en 2007 la politique de la sncf
c'était le tarif kilométrique
aujourd'hui c'est la politique des prix
qui fluctuent en fonction de la demande
on est à l'envers de ce qu'il faut faire
il faut rendre les pois les trains
accessible vous remercie la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée